[Music]
n
a
[Music]
n
I
[Music]
a
[Applause]
[Music]
w
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
oh
I know it's
wrong but I don't
[Music]
care the fire is
strong but I don't
care all I ever want to be is eyes where
eyes lips where lips skin please skin s
pleas s eyes where eyes lips where lips
skiny skin s
ARS feel it now now now now think about
it later feel it now now now now think
about it later feel it now now now now
think about it later feel now now now
now think about it
[Music]
later the damage is
done but I don't
care
[Music]
you're worth the
cost I don't
care all I ever want to be is eyes for
eyes lips for lips skin for skin sin for
sin eyes for eyes lips for your lips M
skin for your
skin
your feel it down down down now think
about it later feel it down now now now
think about it later feel it down now
now now think about it later feel it
down now down now think about it
[Music]
later hold I want
is eyes where eyes lips where lips skip
be skin sa
[Music]
your as the world entered an
unprecedented crisis Magnus Carlson and
chess 24 acted quickly to create the
first online chess tour of its kind
working 24/7 we brought together the
best players in the world for the
largest online prize fund ever broadcast
live in 10 languages the tour innovated
and filled the void created by the lack
of in-person play reaching more people
than any online chess event
ever there was fun and laughter
okay it's time for Russian hak to attack
internet in
[Music]
Norway Last Hope come
on there was tension and controversy not
just make
moves yeah then give up the
phone this is hopeless Anish is fast
these days
interesting that
resigned
okay okay so we will have a fantastic
match tomorrow I'm
sure Yan is angry as hell
now but an also CAU his rhythm so let's
see it will be really fantastic there
were instructive learning moments we
have this covered E6 was a very strong
move for neia she opens up the diagonal
of the queen and at the same time shots
out the D5 Bishop from the defense black
has to play Rook E7 to protect the cor
and the seventh ring but now the queen
comes from the F5 Queen F2 threatening
Rook F7 and it's curtains so the
position is collapsing right now here
black has to resign and there was lots
of great
chairs w wow wow it's really uh an
incredible game like showing how a
complet lost position can gradually turn
into winning position if you just trade
all the right pieces it's really this
game is really a master pass on on the
trades what you should be trading and
what not and when I said that trading
the queens and the Bishops uh is good
for black I never imagined it would ever
happen because it's just it was so far
away from that wow and it's resignation
from ding four unique online events and
a grand final made up the Magnus Carlson
chess tour and the world took
notice the Magnus Carlson chess tour has
been the most watched online chess event
in history already it has become the
world's most prestigious series of
online tournaments as the first season
approaches its conclusion we want your
help to do something even bigger our
partner for the tour final is Kea the
nonprofit with a mission to expand
Financial access to help underserved
communities Kea does incredible work
providing microloans to help people
around the world create opportunity for
themselves and their communities when
the pandemic started Kea set up a Global
covid-19 Response fund to help small
businesses get back on their feet their
target to raise $50 million to support
thousands of people around the world
chess 24 wants to help make that happen
during the tour's final we will be
donating 50% of all proceeds from new
premium memberships to Kaa Go premium
and you will not just be supporting us
and getting the best chess entertainment
out there you will be supporting people
in times of need through Kaa and if you
are premium already you you can buy
sponsored premium memberships for
schools in cities and countries of your
choice in our shop Let's show how chess
can play its part
[Music]
together
practically I think this position is
just lost because without that increment
at least you know that you can fight try
to play very quickly and your opponent
might run out of time but if there is
inclement and even your opponent has
more time then you really have this
impression that he will keep on playing
this position until you just die yeah I
mean and maybe you will even be happy to
die finally because it just already
enough is enough yeah Stu Stu stop the
torture as you said about your game
we
[Music]
my first impression is that Bishop F5 is
a sign that things have gone a little
bit
wrong um it feels like white
is very close to
uh to sort of consolidating and having a
better position there
[Music]
but
hello and welcome back to chess 24 this
is the Magnus Carlson chest St
benefiting key
final the last stop on the tour and
potentially it could be the last day for
Daniel du as he plays a two set catch up
to Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru took a twom
match lead yesterday in a Inc convincing
style which means that Daniel must win
on demand today to be able to take the
match further essentially it also means
that Daniel needs to win the remaining
three matches to make it to the finals
Hikaru looking extremely strong there
and looks like he's got one foot in the
finals already Magnus Carlson dingler
and that was an that was an exciting
match Magnus wrapped it up in three
games in pure Magnus style giving
absolutely no chance as the world
champion himself said that Ding just it
just seemed like he never got it going
and uh after day one the way things had
gone for Magnus we know when he's up
against the wall he strikes back and
that's what he did the score in that
match match is level so an extremely
critical day for ding because I feel
that if you if you need to play catch up
against the world champion that makes
things extremely difficult so today both
these matches are very very crucial and
of course qualifying to the finals also
guarantees the player a very cool payday
of $80,000 take a look at what they are
fighting for so The Losers of the
semi-finals go back home with $40,000
while the runner up off the tour gets
80,000 and the winner a very very cool
$1
140,000 also of course we are in day
three and as we were talking about it
that Hikaru needs one more win in his
match against Daniel to make it to the
finals it's a it's a best of five so the
first player to have a three set Victory
qualifies and goes through and they're
going to be playing as we've gotten used
to the format so far
the same format which is four games of
Rapid we're going to be seeing today
with a Time control of 15 minutes with a
10-second increment in case there's a
tie that goes into the Blitz and if
Blitz is a tie then it goes into the
Armageddon and talking about the
Armageddon a lot of you have been asking
how are the colors decided in the
Armageddon uh for the for the semis and
for the finals Magnus Carlson and Daniel
dubov have the right to choose the color
for the armagedon because their
qualification was on winning winning the
Invitational as and for Daniel it was
the Linder Abby rapid challenge while
Hikaru and ding qualified based on their
cumulative score because Magnus won the
other two events so Magnus and Daniel
have the right to choose the colors in
Armageddon and uh let's Also let's let's
talk about what happened yesterday we
saw a very dramatic shift from from the
game play from the fireworks that we
witnessed on day one they was all about
positional strategic chess slow chess
and uh I think in that Magnus showed
that he just his understanding and the
way he played the end games I think it
was just phenomenal to see him in action
that's where he really he really shines
and one got the feeling that if ding
wants a chance a shot at the finals he's
got to go for more for more aggressive
and attacking and combative play because
it's really hard when Magnus Carlson
goes into these slightly better end
games just the way he plays and talking
about his style of end games we've got
some really cool news for all of you
chessel has released a free course a
free lesson actually by the world
champion himself it's a free end game
Lesson by Magnus Carlson himself Magnus
is considered to be one of the best
endgame players of all times I think
this whole Trend this whole shift in
Trend that we've seen in chess where
players now play a lot more than they
used to before they continue positions
which which are seemingly equal they
continue playing end games I think he's
had a huge role to play in that and uh I
think his we've seen him make something
out of out of apparently nothing in in
end games that probably a lot of us
would consider equals so he's if you
want to learn your end games I think
just no better person than one of the
greatest players of all time in end game
play and in this course uh uh John
Bartholomew and Magnus Carl
both talk about the various aspect of
end game play it's a free lesson it's a
teaser for the main cause that chessel
will be releasing the Magnus DCH end
game course and uh but this one's a
great one because they analyze one of
the games from the 2013 World
Championship against vishan that Magnus
uh Magnus eventually won the World
Championship and uh just talk about it
talks about uh how to place your pieces
the pce play during end game how to
fight for initiative how to find find
something in positions that seemingly
have nothing in them so if you're
looking for improving your end games
definitely check out this free lesson
it's it's got exercises for you to solve
a lot of stuff have a look at that it's
a teaser for the upcoming Magnus Touch
cost on end game play highly recommend
it and uh yes the other uh the other big
story for us is of course always our
interaction with all of you and making
you a part of this event so let's take a
look at your impact chess stories that
we had on
Twitter we had Tio riding in with it's
rough for ding Daniel is too young but
has potential watching from the games I
think I know who's going to the finals
you know I get I get what you're saying
and uh I think I think it's safe to say
that Hikaru looks like he's on his road
to final I think it's going to be
extremely it's going to be nothing short
of a miracle if Daniel dubov wins the
next three sets back toback I think this
is a very inform very confident Hikaru
Nakamura an extremely consistent Hikaru
that we're seeing here and Daniel has a
Monumental task in front of him but
first up he needs to win today to keep
the match going and uh yes Magnus
Carlson dingler and I I mean like we
we've spoken about this several times
Magnus is a favorite in this he's he's
again somebody who's dominated the tour
he's he's cruised and crashed through it
but day one showed us the potential that
Ding has he I think it's really
important that the kind of positions
that are coming on the board need to be
the ones in which the world champion
perhaps doesn't feel as comfortable and
that is something that Ding failed to do
yesterday let's move on to the next
one we had Ivan writing in Grandmaster
Ian sov I do not think except first
match first game naid off and the
Armageddon I do not think middle games
dingler is aiming for versus Magnus are
good choices but let's see so far result
is on his side I think this was around
the time that game two had just a match
two had uh yesterday's matches had just
started and I completely agree with this
and I think this is what we've been
talking about that the games just need
to be a little uh I think the positions
just need to be a lot more crazier and
Messier to be able to put the world
champion out of his comfort zone and
that's where I think the players have a
good shot against Magnus but also as
Magnus himself said that he had a much
more sane approach yesterday probably
good for mental health as he put it
himself for the players going for more
solid structures and more solid lines so
of course uh he himself chose not to go
for the Sicilian but played E4 E5 in uh
with with the black pieces also did not
give the Armageddon game Saw ding employ
a very interesting and a combative
structure against the London system
going G6 uh fan chatwing the bishop but
he never got that chance uh to do all of
that yesterday let's see what happens
today let's move on to the next
one we had Edward writing in with Al the
exciting for spectators it seems to me
that the rapid time control match format
is very demanding and tiring for the
players what is the commentator's
personal Favorite Time control for
competitions um we are I think that's a
great question and we are going to
getting uh uh yes and Peter in on it but
before we do that a quick reminder that
this bar that you see below me right now
is uh uh is the bar that shows the
amount of contributions that we as a
chess Community have raised for for K's
response to covid-19 to support and to
help businesses that have been impacted
that have struggled because of the
pandemic so pandemic hit businesses in
isolated communities in underserved
communities uh to help them out Kaa Kaa
uh does micr lending on zero interest
it's a not for-profit organization and
chess 24 is extremely proud to support
this cause to go the full circle to give
us all the entertainment that we've had
with the Magnus Carlson chess store
during the pandemic and then to use
chess to give back to the community as
well and uh you can contribute and you
can contribute to that by going premium
buying the premium membership for
yourself but also you could gift premium
memberships and 50% of all uh of all
premium memberships during the Magnus
Carlson chest off final will be will go
to help Kaa borrowers and as I was
saying that you can go premium yourself
or you could uh you could gift and we've
seen we've seen Grandmaster Peter leer
do that he's his contribution we've seen
Grand Master vasel Ian do it grandmas
David Martinez uh we've had amazing
contributions from some of the very very
big names Magnus Carlson has pledged 10%
of his winning prize money towards the
cause so join all of us and uh improve
your chess but also give back to the
community by supporting chess and on
that note I do see that we we are joined
by uh by Yas and VA so let's get this
question up by Edward um and I think we
had a really interesting and a
fascinating conversation with uh with
Magnus yesterday about his stake on the
world championship format and the uh the
different time controls what role they
play I think for me personally I do
really enjoy the rapid and Blitz but I
think my favorite has to be the over
theboard classical format I think uh I
think the the Fisher the 90 minute with
with a 30- second increment is the one
that I like the most I don't find it too
long but I find it I find it enough to
to not go crazy over the board and uh
you know let the insanity of the clock
take over and we had an interesting take
in the Legends of Chess especially
regarding the Armageddon I think
Armageddon as a format as a variant in
chess U variant is probably not the
right word but as a time format I think
it's super exciting to watch it's super
thrilling to watch but it does take away
from the chess I think we had vishy say
this as well that you know it does it
doesn't remain about the game anymore
the clock takes over what is happening
on the board so but then you need
something to kind of decide the result
so I think all these are really exciting
formats and for online I don't see a
classical time control working I think
that's we need to be on the edge of our
seats and that's the nature of online
play so it's really exciting to see
rapid and Blitz but my heart is with
classical play and I do see yes is with
us so let's bring yes into the
conversation welcome yes how are you
today well thank you Tanya I I'm well
and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us I've been listening Tanya to
uh Edward's question and yes he's
absolutely right these time controls are
extraordinarily demanding on the players
it's almost like you're feeling pressure
from the moment the clock is started and
the Blitz in the Armageddon I mean if
your heart isn't beating you know loudly
during an Armageddon game I mean you're
not alive um I of course was raised in a
time of 40 moves for two and a half
hours and then a German so I was really
really used to an incredibly slow Bas it
doesn't work for
online uh tournaments quite clearly so
whether the players like it or not this
is the de facto time control and I just
also want to say on that note it's not
just demanding on the players it's
demanding on the commentators because
man we're doing our best to to keep up
with the players and look at the clock
and it we don't feel like we even get a
chance to take a break Peter uh your
perspective on the most demanding time
controls yeah hello Tanya hello y hello
everybody very nice to be joining again
yeah this time control issue it's uh
it's a forever debate of course as Tanya
already mentioned I fully agree that
there are different perspectives and we
if we are thinking about online chess
and how to promote the game and how to
make it more exciting than this is
exactly the format I mean I played it
myself personally I would prefer the
rapid time control to be 20 minutes but
I also understand that uh this 15
minutes is even more Dynamic so uh The
Spectators enjoy it probably even more
and the other problem is that the longer
the time control the less games you can
play and in this format that we are
seeing four games a day by the players
and eventual tie breaks uh this is
already anyway very demanding so I I
love this format on on the whole I do
agree that classical time control is
something that we simply cherish because
this is the tradition and as you already
mentioned you said that you used to play
with completely different time control
the very old classical with two and a
half hours for 40 moves uh I was raised
with two hours for 40 moves and so on 7
hours time control
to be honest I still love that very very
much simply probably for the fact that I
used to be much more active in my
younger years and I got used to that
time control and all these increments
with 30 seconds whatever feels very
artificial to me we already discussed
this with Tanya also in the question and
answers during the Legends tournament
that my heart is not taking this
increment I mean this 30 seconds or 10
seconds I feel like I can't make the
most out of it while I see that my open
hands are exactly using that to to their
benefit so everybody is different
everybody prefers something else but of
course the classical control with this
very interesting online rapid format I
think this is just fine Peter I remember
that Q&A and I think the one thing that
stood out for me was we had this
question about uh what superpower you'd
want and you know all the other Grand
Masters wanted to either have be able to
fly or be invisible and Peter just
wanted the superpower to stay calm
during the time trouble during time
scramble so I think that sort of uh that
sort of told us about how you feel but
you know you guys were talking about the
grueling format where with four rapid
games and then Blitz Games I I actually
I know it's super demanding on the
players but I truly think that that's
what makes this entire tour a a test by
fire because it's you have to have that
consistency that stamina it's literally
the survival of the fittest and the best
and I think uh Magnus has always been
the ambassador of of the most of taking
on the biggest challenges and I think
that's what he brings with this format
because he's also he's also part of it
nobody's excused from it and at the end
of it it comes to who is able to handle
the pressures that come with the clock
who is able to handle the stamina the
big question about stamina with this
crazy format which goes on for four to
five hours so I really think it's a test
of many different skills that makes one
a true athlete and talking about it also
being difficult for the commentators
maybe for you yes and Peter it is and
you don't get on a break but I just get
to hang out with all our audience and
chat with them on Twitter and bring out
all the fun stuff so I'm loving it and
talking about talking about Twitter
another reminder to all of you that yes
please be a part of this uh of the
tournament we love having you on it and
and the official hashtag of the event is
impact chess because this is what this
finals is all about it is about the
impact of Chess on us through this
pandemic but also how we can impact the
community positively through chess so uh
it's the whole theme so send us your
your stories about how chess has
impacted your life or a moment which uh
which had a big impact on you because of
Chess so don't forget to use the hashtag
impact chess and we'll make sure that we
get we speak about those stories on our
show and uh yes with that we've still
got a couple of minutes uh before we
start off so let's also get Peter and
y's take on uh on a very important
aspect which I think is going to play a
big big role today which is going to be
the openings and uh because I think the
kind of positions as Grand Master Ian
sov also said the kind of position
positions that are going to arise will
set the tone for the match uh Peter and
I want to throw this question to you are
we going to be looking at a different
approach especially from Ding and Daniel
uh from what happened yesterday as far
as the openings are concerned well I
mean first let me talk about dingl land
situation you know it's very funny
whenever somebody wins uh people like to
say that ah this guy is in form in shape
when you lose then suddenly you are not
in form and you not in shape but uh this
is all much more complex the point is
that I think what dingl really needs is
some really stable opening with black
and he has to rely on his main opening
but what we have seen yesterday that
against one D4 he didn't know it feels
to me like the shock that he encountered
during the Legends tournament against
Magnus Carson when in the anti Moscow
variation Magnus hit him with some very
big powerful computer analysis in this
Ultra Sharp complex game took his
confidence away and another thing is
that his other weapon is the The semar
Rush with black where Magnus had been
very powerful against Anish giri in
their final in one of the events before
in in chessel so this puts I think a lot
of pressure on ding if he managed to
find a way to deal with magnus's one D4
then the match is very sharp and
anything can happen but he keeps on
having this problem and he has to side
step from his
power then it puts also too much
pressure on his white game because he
feels like if he's not punching with
white then he will be suffering with
black it's a very unpleasant situation
to face and also before we have uh
liftoff I I want to bring in I think one
of the very interesting conversations
that Yas had with Hikaru because as we
were saying the entire theme of the
Magnus Carlson Chester benefiting Kaa
finals has been impact chess connect
with us using that hashtag and also I
think what Hikaru said to ask about uh
about the entire about how chess what
what a positive tool it has been during
the pandemic was was very fascinating
take a look at uh at what he had to say
I do very strongly feel that in terms of
being a game that is out there and is
known I think chess is by far and way
the most popular people know what chess
is so even if somebody doesn't really
know how to play the game of chess
everybody when they see the Kings the
Queens they see the pieace they know
what the game is and I think the fact
there's so much uh so much exposure out
there there are a lot of people who
played the game when they were young
they they didn't play it Beyond say
learning from their parents or or
playing in Middle School in the chess
club but but they are coming back and
they remember it and because there's
that that huge reach of Chess I think
that's what it is it's more there are a
lot of people who played for whatever
period of time when they were younger
and now they're remembering because
they're they're getting on Twitch or
they're they're just watching watching
things on the Internet it's like oh
chess that game yeah I played it many
many years ago and and I think uh at
least I know my experience I think for
many people we do look back very
nostalgically on our childhood and I
think that is one of the biggest drivers
as well is that they're all these people
who have these very fond memories of
playing it as as kids and now they're
adults and and they're they're they're
remembering what a great game it
is yes indeed I think one of the most
popular games it makes us nostalgic all
of us have played it at some time and
and now better than ever now more than
ever we all want to get better at chess
so definitely one uh a great time to
consider going premium and working on
your game and at the same time
supporting our communities um uh yes so
yes what did you think about hikaru's
Tak on it and the whole popularity of
Chess that's happened during this time
well I I must say that I completely
agree with him and that it's a great
opportunity for people who used to play
chess to get back into it but I tell you
Tanya we got liftoff we've got liftoff
so let's talk about Chess and we'll get
back to this later all right uh Peter we
have uh the the same English that Danel
and Hikaru have been arguing about in
the first two days what's happening yeah
one thing I want to mention somehow I
have the feeling or the impression that
we always see Daniel duol Hikaru
Nakamura game start first and and I
wonder you know are the players really
so uh eager to to get at each other's
throats because yeah finally now also
dingl and Magnus car game has just
started the first move one night FC but
meanwhile we already have a really
complex English opening I think one of
those that maybe you are quite familiar
with maybe not exactly move P move but
strategic wise so we'll be very very
interesting to to discuss this with you
exactly well uh the the take that Danel
had been uh playing um yesterday or was
it the day before it was like A3 B4 Rook
B1
right remember um Peter that he was
trying to get the queenside going and
it's funny uh I actually there's a
really really really talented Dutch uh
junior player Hing Ting uh who comes
over uh every now and then uh um and we
we get to do a little training together
and he likes to play the English and I
recommended to him this exact setup that
Danel has played and the idea behind
White's um move order is to delay
playing the move D2 D3 in other words
not to use that move and in an Ideal
World black would allow white to play
Knight C5 and D2 D4 so white really
really wants to play D2 D4 and not D2 D3
if white could get in D4 then you could
see that his two Bishops are doing great
and Black's Bishops on the other hand
are more or less defensively minded so
um not a great Advantage is not is not
like as you said that I I remember that
game from the chessable Masters that you
mentioned Peter uh Magnus versus Anish
giri I think it was one of the greatest
brilliancies of the tour uh but this is
not going
to get as unrap capured it's just
another approach as the other approaches
that Danel used weren't really
working yeah I mean also the line that
he kind of surprised the hearu yesterday
was probably a one game idea they
already had this match and maybe Daniel
thought that aha I still have a little
idea somewhere where my opponent might
not expect any trouble so let me try it
but obviously both players thought that
yeah black should be fine there if black
knows what to do and the way Daniel
treats the position now with this much
slower Bly Bishop B2 Luke C1 more
strategical more solid uh way but uh
solid doesn't mean that it's not
complicated it's it's very complicated
just a very solid stable setup from from
White side and uh it guarantees a
complex fight exactly now we saw the
move F7 F6 which is kind of like black
is saying okay I'll go along with
whatever program that you've got planned
for me uh tell me what you want to do
and after giving this I think brilliant
understanding about the position where
you aspire to play the move D2 D4 and
not D2 D3 right on Q it's the
commentator's curse Peter welcome to
chess
commentating
the players do the opposite D2 D3 uh so
I think uh for me a question might have
been well why didn't white play what I
had prescribed Knight C5 followed by D4
and maybe we'll see it another game uh
because it seems to me the Knight on e4
looks pretty but it's actually doing a
lot more on the C5 square and again I
think that white is aspiring to play D2
D4 he did play D D2 D3 now it just looks
to me again Peter you're you're our
chess expert it's kind of just a uh
reversed uh
Sicilian yeah exactly I mean it's this
the typical uh dragon position when
white the opposite side would not play
principle way so it's very logical from
now from the white side that okay I
managed to avoid all those complicated
crazy dragons so let me just enjoy the
dragon as it is uh but but the
psychological uh impact of this whole
stuff is that now black is not fighting
for Advantage and exactly those moves
like this uh let's just go back moves
like Rook E8 Rook C1 Bishop f8 this is a
these are very natural stabilizing moves
it guarantees a very solid setup for
Black but if you do it from the white
side it might feel like okay this is not
that ambitious with black you don't want
to be ambitious you want to neutralize
your opponent's idea first and I believe
that also this Knight E4 F6 has the same
effect because black just wants to make
sure that aha okay maybe are thinking
about opening up the position with D4 or
whatsoever but I'm ready for it I will
exchange as many pieces as possible and
you don't really have any Target so in
this regard I felt like D3 not changing
uh strategy since you committed yourself
to F6 which is a move you anyway want to
do but okay there is no harina now from
White side please show me what you got
next Black played the move A5 and now
white played Knight
C5 and now I think it's it's very
interesting because a move had been
played a decision by Hikaru which if he
would not know the position he would
never ever uh do in something like 20 30
seconds he played the move A5 A4 which
is
a which is just a pawn sacrifice a
positional Pawn sacrifice but if you
don't know where lead then you just
cannot make uh make up your mind so
quickly exactly and he as you said he
did in fact play that move very quickly
so that's let's assume that the that at
least for Hikaru he's still in his
preparation and you were complaining
well you didn't complain but Peter you
mentioned 15 minutes versus 20 minutes
it always seems whenever I look at the
games between Danel and Hikaru they're
starting with 17 minutes they blitzed up
their opening moves uh and got to the
position shall we just take a a quick
Gander at magnus's game as you said I
don't think it was intentionally
staggered later but it just seemed that
the the games do start a little bit
later on dings board yeah and it was
very nice that you mentioned it exactly
that's the reason why I feel that I need
the 20 minutes because these guys are
just so fast you know I feel like only
my clock is sticking right from the
beginning and it adds adds to the
pressure of course these players are
playing so so many times I mean Hikaru
is like an internet online monster so it
comes much more natural for them but for
me just to make sure that I have things
under control take some extra additional
time but yeah as you said let's move to
the dingl and Magnus carang game and
this is a very interesting opening uh
fight debate between the two
players one could when you look at it it
looks like some G King indan with geld
G3 but in fact it started from a r move
order with one Knight F3 this is again
typical modern chest you you hibrid all
kinds of different move orders in order
to to try to force your opponent into
maybe some move order where after you
can switch directions and uh confront
him in some field where he's not feeling
so comfortable yeah I always appreciated
these foxy hybrid
variations where if I know my opponent
as you say is a grunfeld player maybe
Kings Indian player I try to trick them
with just some like offbeat opening move
order to get the the game to go in a
channel that I want and here we see a
kind of like you say it started as a
ready then it kind of switches to a
king's Indian with D6 and C6 but then it
switches again to a
grunfeld with a with a with a D5
included it's like
what yeah exactly but it it's a very
special variation I mean first of all
let's just mention that uh during the
tournament in Legends Magnus we I had
this position exactly against Magnus and
Magnus played C5 against me and after
castles Knight C6 D5 Knight A5 we were
debating this uh old classical position
with some new twists but magnos now
comes up with little bit of a surprise
the move C6 uh it's it's not like a
surprise in itself because there are
many thousand of games for it but I
don't really recall Magnus ever really
using this C6 move and to be honest this
cast's Bishop F5 line is getting more
and more popular and the move Knight G5
is almost exclusively played by
ding wow this is the this is how he gets
this gomf structure with D6 D5 so black
is basically forced to play D6 D5
because you are threatening to get space
with E2 E4 so that's how we got here
exactly and I really kind of want to
attribute maybe falsely but uh um
Fabiana Karana is coming up with his
Bishop F5 I remember in the old days
lubash Kavik he liked the move order
Queen A5 which is kind of tricky move
order because sometimes he went Queen A5
to H5 so he could trade light Square
Bishops and sometimes he played Queen A5
to
A6 just to tickle the pawn on B6 and to
try to upset his opponent but yeah
Bishop F5 has become a little bit more
popular I didn't realize that uh that
Ding uh was uh
the was the provocator of Knight G5 okay
and E2 E4 is that is that so serious
like black cannot play H6 Peter and say
why did you move your knight yeah if you
do H6 then white plays E4 that's that's
very important and you harass the Bishop
from F5 and if the bishop has to move
then already you have no problem re
moving back your knight as well and you
say thank you very much I achieved what
I wanted and do you really want to have
your Pawn on H6 and the bishop on G4
where do you go from there this is
actually the the whole point behind and
I believe there was a game I recall
dingan versus Fabiano Carana in one of
this rapid Blitz or whatever which maybe
continued Knight G5 Knight G5 Queen C8
E4 and then the bishop moved somewhere
and later black was trying to get Bishop
HC in with thanks to the queen on C8 I
see I see and uh for those of you who
are joining us late again uh shame on
you because you might might have missed
the very big news that uh a a chessable
endgame lesson is being offered freely
so today you can sign up you can go to a
chessel site that will also provide a
link throughout the show where you can
sign up and I'm not kidding you get a a
20- minute lesson from Magnus Carlson in
an endgame uh where he discusses an
endgame from his world championship
match against fishy n so do sign up for
that in case you're late now after D5
the players quickly move to Pace uh
Peter yeah exactly I mean white has to
hurry up because otherwise the Knight on
G5 will simply feel misplaced so white
makes use of this that the diagonal is
open the pawn on D5 is under pressure
White Queen targets also the B7 Pawn so
it gets very forc very tactical black
plays Queen
B6 is basically a pawn sacrifice C takes
D5 Queen takes B3 a takes B3 Knight
takes i c takes D5 Knight takes D5
Knight takes D5 Bishop takes D5 and
Knight C6 it's it's now very much in the
Gom fed spirit and to be honest just not
much long before the Legends tournament
I happen to check this position myself
out of curiosity and uh I felt like
black is holding here
really I mean I always tease Peter
Fiddler I'd say you know like he's this
uh groom Feld expert right and he's not
happy unless he's a pwn down because
groom Feld players love to sacrifice a
pawns for the initiative but I got to
ask you what is it that white did wrong
that makes you think the compensation
sufficient for a Peter I don't think why
did anything wrong it's it's just that
it's not so easy in mod chess to to get
any advantage and if you are already
interested about Theory and so on U I
can also highlight that here instead of
the move short Castle the move E2 E4 had
been played by my student uh Vincent ker
in the bill
tournament against Arad nid and he won a
very very nice game against aradi so now
you understand maybe where my knowledge
of all these lines come from and why I
suggested for example E4 to to Vincent
against this variation just simply to
avoid the potential Pawn sacrifice so
let's go back we do have a pawn
sacrifice and um I you know I feel
whenever some the top Grand Master has
made you know research and done a lot of
work uh I really feel reluctant to probe
and ask so where did it all lead so I
have to I'm not going to ask you to
reveal what you think are all the best
moves but at this exact moment uh if you
were looking at the board with fresh
eyes and you didn't have the knowledge
you have uh how would you assess it and
what plans would you foresee the players
making well to be honest I don't have to
hide anything here and I have already
given away way too much information but
but simply the point is that I I felt
like I used to be a GFI player myself
and I analyz the gly stuff quite a lot
with with both colors and my instinct
was saying that this somehow will end up
in a draw with modern technology and
then I let computer R little bit in this
position and the only thing I remember
about it that after thinking for for
quite some time the engine uh didn't
really uh came up with any idea which I
wanted to remember I just felt like yeah
it uh it proved my feeling that this is
this is too it's going to be too drawish
because what I feel that sooner or later
maybe in order to keep the pawn white
will have to depart from his light
Square Bishop but if you are really
considering for example taking on C6
it's definitely not a move to consider
but then you already immediately feel
that with the two Bishops I mean black
will definitely have uh
enough
compensation uh if you don't mind just
continue the line before we jump back to
the hikaro game uh developing is always
good Bishop E3 I have in my mind's eye
the idea of Rook A3 or maybe Rook A6 to
develop to double uh Rooks on the a file
and hey hey hey I'm a pawn up yeah you
are Pawn up you are welcome to be Pawn
up up I don't mind I mean I feel that I
have always this break like E5 breaking
up your stabilizer the D4 pawn and once
I open up this diagonal then the two
Bishops and this Knight on G5 is a
little bit out of the game it will
require one extra Tempo to come back
besides I also have some ideas like rook
fb8 and you play Rook A3 but I will hit
you on B3 whenever you take I will also
take all your pawns I see it's just
somehow to draw I cannot exactly now I
explained this move P move but I have
this feeling that the tendency is very
much that it's draw anding has played
the move E3 which is I think much more
human just to keep this bishop however
this case the bishop on C1 is an eternal
problem and black still has the idea of
breaking the center with something like
E5 and uh and it seems to be enough
compensation for the sacrifice Point
yeah just to be supportive of your
overall assessment I in my match with
Anatole karpov that we had played in St
Louis I got a situation where you know I
had an extra Pawn but his two Bishops uh
were were were sufficient compensation
and he made a comfortable draw now uh
back to uh Hikaru and as Tanya mentioned
at the opening of the show uh duboff
unfortunately it's not just a must-win
situation today but really it's a
must-win situation three days in a row
as he trails in the match two sets to
null Peter yeah I think I would like to
add something about the psychological
impact uh in my opinion it would be very
very uh bad strategy from Hikaru if he
would just lean back saying okay I'm too
up and I just have to be solid and
sooner or later I will win this match no
no because believe me exactly a player
like Daniel who is now in this situation
that he has to win he will mobilize all
his energy all his reserves in order to
try to fight back and if he suddenly
feels like he gets another chance then
he will be newborn so Hikaru has to keep
his momentum going and and try to finish
this match really today because
otherwise it can still get very very
dramatic all right and if you could
return to the position Peter when we
left it and then we could catch up with
the players we had just seen A5 A4 uh we
traded Knights on A4 and we'll pick up
the action yes one thing I would like to
mention because I think it's very
important behind the idea A5 A4 is that
this Knight on C5 as you mentioned it's
a very irritating Knight and black wants
to get rid of it but on the other hand
you also feel that maybe if you take uh
with the bishop and you give up your
pair of Bishop then this this structure
with the the two kns and this PA
structure and White's very harmonious
flexible setup might guarantee white a
slight age which he exactly needs and
black doesn't want to give this and
another way there is no other way to get
rid of this Knight unless black really
forces the things and after A5 A4 white
is not really able to capture with bakes
A4 I believe because then you have this
double attack with Knight takes A4
hitting the rook and the bishop solving
all problems so in this regard white was
forced to take with Knight on A4 so
black did sacrifice the pawn but got rid
of this very annoying knight from C5
exactly and then after Bishop E6 the
game continued Knight D2 okay um and
just well giving back the pawn uh that
suddenly didn't feel so
discomforting uh if we had played A2 A3
it's it's it's not the most beautiful
Pawn in the world let's be clear Peter
but it's
mine so if he if he had kept the pawn
and I don't know taken control over the
B4 Square yay
um H how would black respond in in in
your mind yeah I think the the key thing
is that this Pawn is not running away
and black with a very solid structure
and
very nice Rook on A8 maybe can just take
it easy and play a very solid move like
Bishop D5 and it's kind of my feeling
that's why Daniel really hurried with
the move Knight D2 because now you can't
really move the Knight if you move the
Knight to D2 you can of course why
wouldn't you but then I just exchange
his Bishops I give a very nice check on
D5 and I feel like yes you got the C4
square but black got way too much
activity the queen from d B1 was not
able to to reach out to B3 and I might
just maybe play Rook A6 Rook E8 hit this
Pawn on A4 and I don't really see how
you're gonna protect it exactly and old
school Michael binck after your Bishop
D5 and E2
E4 and d and followed by D4 is too slow
in your
view I mean it's it's interesting but
then your OPP on a is is going to be for
at the end of the day exactly any trades
I was hoping yeah I was hoping that C7
or B7 might be weak but it just it just
feels very hard uh for white uh to do
that much all right let's let's continue
with the game as uh Donald did give back
his A2 Pawn he played Knight D2 and then
what happened Peter yeah I mean it's
also very much Duo style I mean he he
prefers initi he wants to be on the on
the attacking side and he prefers to
give up give back the material and with
KN B3 he makes sure that yes my friend
you took this Pawn on A2 but uh you will
have to depart from your light Square
bishop and if you get rid of this light
Square Bishop then suddenly especially
after the move F6 all this all this
light squares and the diagonal and
another diagonal on the G2 B7 and Queen
coming to B3 so this is the idea but
Hikaru must have calculated very very
deeply look at also the clock situation
it it one can already see how much
energy and effort the players had put
into this game so we see
some I have to update just a second so
yeah Rook A1 Rook A6 Knight A5 one would
say brilliancy wow but believe me I
think Daniel had already foreen this
move and he played the move Knight D2
right so Tak Rook takes
A2 and Rook B5 I would say that it's a
key move it's a key concept of Hikaru he
has to keep this Rook because if he
takes on A2 Queen B check king h8 queen
takes A2 it will be much more difficult
for black to to keep the queen side
going and now we are again talking about
compensation for the pawn but here white
can even probably try to to play for an
advantage
yes this does look like one of those
positions where the two Bishops and most
especially because uh the queenside pawn
structure somehow it's it's hard to I if
if black could magically play two moves
in a row Knight D4 and C6 hey you know
we all raise our hands and say I'd like
to be black but I'm afraid that we're
losing the B7 Pawn so that was why in
your view keeping the Rooks by Hikaru
was a very important judgment yeah I
think it was the key key move of his
concept with Rook B5 and we see exactly
he gets the moves you wanted to get
thanks to this Rook B5 Tempo so Rook B5
Bishop C3 White had to lose one little
half Tempo which gave hial the chance to
to jump in with the Knight to D4 now
Rook B2 had been played Rook takes B2
Bishop B2 and okay uh you want a Tempo
but still you have to be careful because
the move C6 which looks very natural can
run into Bishop takes D4 probably e
takes D4 Queen B3 check king h8 queen
takes B7 and believe me despite the fact
that it looks like opposite colored
Bishops and not so much material this
can be really ugly and very dangerous
practically exactly one of the reasons
for that is the Pawn on D4 really kills
the dark Square Bishop whereas White's
light Square bishop and thanks to the
pawn being on F6 white gets gets to play
on the light square is much easier he
can put his b after he takes a Pawn on
C6 he can try to make a battery against
G8 he can put his Bishop on e4 and try
to Target H7 uh I don't like being uh
prodded and probed here uh this is a
nice Advantage for white no guarantee of
winning of course but two result game
certainly Hikaru doesn't want anything
to do with this position yeah but on the
other hand look at this he went King h8
which already indicates that he's ready
to uh wow to agree to this position with
Bishop D4 and white taking on B7 at
least he's with Pawn on C7 he has more
stability but one thing is for sure
white has very nice pressure um could
you I know that that that's actually a
very very difficult question to answer
why didn't hikaro play B6 we understood
that c oh
yeah B6 sorry we understood that C6
still allowed the queen B3 check which
explains King h8 but B6 uh Peter yeah I
guess that maybe there should be some
concrete reason with e3
coming right and if we go back to E6 we
might run into Bishop C6 yeah okay this
is starting to get a little bit
uncomfortable right yeah exactly I mean
because all this Bishop A3 maybe I could
have even started with Bishop A3 I mean
here I don't know I have so many options
I mean looks too good for white already
agreed yeah so Hikaru didn't like it and
it you know this was my feeling as well
that this Knight D2 Bishop A2 Knight BC
once I saw Daniel do it I immediately
started appreciating it and I felt like
wow it's a it's a it's a great idea and
it shows how much Daniel is eager to to
fight back in this match exactly and
again uh for those of your joining us
late uh this uh semifinal has been all
Hikaru uh thus far as he leads two sets
to nil uh needs just one more set to
book his seat into the finals and as
you're updating the board uh position we
have seen uh Danel grabbing the pawn on
B7
and this is
a you know it's funny hearu came on
yesterday and he said he was really
happy everything was good except that
one ending with the major piece ending
of Queen and Rook where he had this weak
Pawn on the sea file he felt that he
should have lost it you
know I don't know about you Peter but
this looks awfully similar to the game
that he described as being very bad for
him um your take on this
ending yeah I mean it's uh I'm pretty
sure Hikaru is not happy with his
position but I think one of these very
important characteristics of Hikaru and
why he's so extremely practical and
successful in all these online formats
and the rapid chess also over the board
and Blitz and everything that he he
likes it or not he doesn't care he knows
that okay he finally end up in this
position he has to try to make the most
of it the best out of it and he starts
to play very quickly and with a lot of
confidence putting pressure on your
opponent and you know you know that you
are better but when your opponent
suddenly blitzes out and you feel like
he always makes the best moves it it
gives you some this impression that aha
this guy believes that he will hold it
and then when he sells you this
impression that he's going to hold this
position then it's much more difficult
to win it against him than against
someone who you see see that the guy is
suffering he understands he believes you
that yeah exactly my opponent played so
well now I will be tortured I will most
probably slowly lose so lot of
psychology there uh to be honest I'm not
sure that I like what Daniel did because
if we go back few moves I mean just at
the position after King h8 there was a
choice that should white take on B7 or
should he take on D4 first and then
capture on B7
right and uh to my mind it felt like
that maybe I would have preferred with
white to go for the opposite colored
Bishop position I believe that black
would have taken most probably the queen
on D4 because structure with e D4 Bishop
takes B7 feels just very very unpleasant
right so you take Queen D4 anyway take
on B7 I understand not much is yet
happening but if my Bishop returns and I
get Queen C2 Rook C1 in and I go H4 H5
King G2 then we all know know that long
terms it can be very bad for black yeah
black still has time so he might be able
to generate some counterplay but still
it it looks uh quite unpleasant to me
for me this is a two result game white
the worst case white draws the best case
he wins I just I never see black winning
these types of Bishop of opposite color
where the structure and again probably
because of the Pawn on F7 Dan went for
this end game with rook and Bishop but
the same color uh bishop and he's gotten
an F4 and King F3 he's
still I mean I'm not saying uh Hikaru
suffering necessarily I still see that
white has an advantage if he can push
him over I we'll see if he can push him
over but um I like that opposite color
position more in terms of Whit's chances
than this one and again uh just
mentioning that we are giving away a
free Magnus Carlson in-game uh
chessable uh course today so go to
chess.com and sign up and get a free
endgame Lesson by our world champion
Magnus Carlson and speaking of Magnus uh
shall we uh Peter go see what's
happening in that game yeah definitely I
mean not that much had happened because
the position is just too too complex but
uh maybe ah okay no it something really
had happened so Magnus first went H6
probably was saying that I want to go E4
E7 E5 but this Knight on G5 and the
bishop on D5 puts too much pressure on
my F7 pawn and I want to free my rook
and in fact the game had already been
drawn with the repetition of moves so
let's just see what has happened H6
Knight E4 Rook fd8 Knight cc is force
because of course white does not want to
give up his light Square Bishop Knight
C3 is played Black plays E5 ex
everything very very logical D takes E5
Bishop takes E5 as I mentioned this this
compensation is just uh just to too much
to handle with with white this bishop on
C1 Rook on F1 all very passive of course
white is Pawn up that's why he is not
running any risk so E4 had been played
Bishop H3 and white had to agree to a
repetition of most with Rook D1 because
if white would go Rook E1 then Knight D4
would hurt him big time with for coming
to F3 or on
C2 so Rook D1 kind of force Bishop G4
Rook F1 white is Pawn up so if white
gets one extra move then he stabilizes
so black has to keep harassing the rook
and there is no way to to step out of
the repetition and draw was agreed it's
only with a halfhearted I'm not I'm not
enthusiastic about my suggestion uh your
take on Bishop takes H6 Rook takes F
Bishop takes F1 King takes F1 two pawns
and a bishop as compensation for an
exchange Peter yeah absolutely I mean
this is the only only question to be
honest uh I'm little bit surprised but I
I believe the players you know I believe
the players and I believe that actually
if white gets a chance to make two more
moves then he will be probably just
better the critical move might be some
direct Knight
B4 hitting hitting this bishop on D5
even sacrificing the B7 Pawn but I just
want activity and let's imagine you take
on B7 I go Rook a B8 suddenly I feel
that I will be just way too active
exactly so Bishop D5 Bishop C3 there's a
lot of forcing sequences and I can
imagine that once I lose the two Bishops
is my counter uh compensation I mean to
say I'm not satisfied okay I don't I
don't see it as whites taking a lot of
risks either but I'm with you on this
one I'm G to believe the players a draw
in the first game as that semi-final
match is one set a piece we'll go back
to the game in progress Peter yeah
absolutely so yeah I I fully agree that
this is a result both players can live
with after all yeah dink had a very
tough day yesterday and the real
question is how he will uh deal with his
black game and he needs to to survive
the black game to gain confidence and if
he survives that then I think he will be
more and more ambitious with white but
right now his mind is probably how I
will deal with my black game and and
Hikaru is when we left after F4 King F7
I mean F4 King G8 King F3 King F7 I was
exactly thinking that if white wants to
get something out of this position then
he has to play the move F4 F5 because
you just cannot let the black king reach
to E6 comfortably right that's uh my my
my take exactly I mean you're grabbing
space and maybe on a very very good day
you get to play King E4 and King
D5 and then then you might be in
business yeah exactly and also fixing
the the pawns on the dark squares one
issue I want to mention because it's
it's very very important it's always a
big question and a big debate and
probably a real Mastery to understand
when such Bishop like the bishop on D6
is a terrible piece and when it looks
like a terrible piece but that actually
it does great job because without this
bishop Black's position would fall apart
then the pawn on C7 would be just to
weak the white Rook would have
immediately entry points not just to the
C7 Pawn but just imagine there is no
Bishop on D6 white goes like Rook C6 and
not only puts pressure on the C7 Pawn
but it would put pressure on the F6 Pawn
cutting black king further down
so it it's it's the soul of Black's
position even if it looks bad this
bishop on D6 keep things together one
big question is how to evoluate in this
position The Exchange of Rooks and the
way we see uh the reaction of the
players white prefers to change the Rook
but Hikaru says no no I understand that
suddenly then after changing the Rooks
my Bishop would be really dead because
then all this protecting of C7 Pawn
would not really make any difference
White's king would just March in as
yasel already indicated so black has to
be alert not to exchange the Rooks yeah
I remember what you're saying there
Grandmaster uh
Romanian Grandmaster oh boy oh boy his
name will come to me in a moment he said
bad Bishops protect good
ponds and I thought that was a very
insightful move insightful uh
understanding uh if you could go back to
that position where the Rooks were were
were were offered for a moment because
one of the things uh I think that a lot
of players should understand about
Bishop endings it's always about whose
Pawn is more important and after the
trade trade on F5 for just a second if
you don't mind Peter and take and play
the move E4
check so that after I don't know King
takes E4 Bishop takes
H2 it's a very reduced Pawn structure
right but whose
Pawn is more important
structure yeah one of the questions is
maybe also what happens in the opponent
game with Bishop F4 right precisely
precisely I mean you have to take I take
and my take is that you have to try to
run with with the King to D6 E5 before I
run to H6 right but yeah it's it's very
difficult to judge with little little
time control one has the feeling that
it's it's very dangerous and the players
have two three minutes and they have to
rely on their Instinct and here you
don't have any Instinct yeah you need
very precise calculation and that's
exactly what I wanted to say about the
time control sometimes you come to a
position where instin you just say oops
uh I shouldn't go there because it's
dangerous and in maybe a classical game
or maybe in an adjourn game where you
have all the time in the world to
calculate uh you would say no no no uh
this this King and pon game is a very
simple draw let me show you how but when
you get into a king and Pawn in game
you've already burned all your Bridges
you know like now you're in it either
it's a draw by force or a win by force
and that was an interesting moment uh
how has how has it evolved since Peter
yeah not much not much has changed
because Hikaru keeps the rook and
disturbs white uh implementing his plan
now with the Rooks on it's not easy to
march in with the King and it's also not
really clear where you are really
planning to March so Hikaru just sticks
to waiting
strategy always attacking
something being as disturbing as
possible yeah yeah and now he played
this idea King E7 King D7 I mean
basically indicating that okay if I can
get my king to D7 how you want to break
and there is no other way than to to
exchange on G6 and try to rely on the H
passer so H4 had been played Rook A8
typical hiar I think he had foreseen all
this that he's in time with Rook h8
because this Rook h8 is a vital move not
not to take on H5 but to play Rook h8
Force white to take on G6 and now you go
Rook G8 and you are out of the woods
beautiful defensive play indeed what an
ending really really nice uh play that
Rook h8 followed by Rook
G8 okay that's that's really really
class and again for those of you uh
today is chessable uh free course day as
Magnus
Carlson and chessable are offering a
free endgame Lesson by the world
champion go to the chessel site and sign
up well as this game looks to me like
it's heading to a draw let me just again
uh set the table and boldly State the
obvious Danel has lost day one and day
two sets he trails in the match so badly
that he not only needs to win today but
to get to the finals he's going to need
to win three sets in a row it's three
days of play uh from uh hikaru's point
of view nothing could be sweeter than
clinching the match with a victory today
as that would book his uh seat at the
table where
$140,000 of the
$300,000 in prize money is waiting for
the winner the runner up earning
$80,000 uh dollars this of course is the
Magnus Carlson finals a competition that
benefits
Kea and as you've been seeing we've got
this wonderful donation bar just below
uh well in this case I can see myself uh
just below me we have the donation bar
as we're seeking to raise
$50,000 to support Kaa in its efforts of
micr loan lending what that means is in
uh developing countries you have
entrepreneurs that really really want to
start businesses and small businesses
and we feel that by supporting K's
efforts and helping these
entrepreneurs uh we can create a
positive feedback loop the covid-19
pandemic has really impacted everybody
throughout the entire world and many
people economically are really hurting
uh chess
24 strangely enough has really benefit
benefited by people who are staying at
home such as yourselves who are watching
uh this broadcast and it was the desire
of the chess 24 to give back to the
community and to support Kaa so anytime
you want to support that donation bar
holy smokes Peter uh it
just as I was talking it blew up I mean
I saw this little green on the left and
it zipped right over and that was very
very generous thank you all for your
support and by the way Peter thank you
again for for your support you donated
a, uh Euros to help uh the premium
members and Hungary uh tell us a little
bit more about your donation and how it
will positively impact the Hungarian
players that you wanted to assist yeah I
mean I'm very very happy to make this
donation because I just felt when when I
first time heard about this that okay if
there is an opportunity of course I have
to I have to make use of it it just so
so nice I have been part of this Magnus
Carson tour not right from the beginning
I joined in May from the Lindor but I
mean really it enraged my my life in
this last half year really much and uh
so really thank you chess 24 for for
doing this so it was not not even a
question I was not even hesitating for a
single second it my heart just said yes
and the question was how and and what to
to do exactly so the I think this was a
very nice idea and I donated
this, uh I donated it partly to the Giza
Modi chess club in saged in my local
town and part of it will go to really
talented young players in Hungary who
will I think benefit a lot I still have
to make my research because I feel that
this premium membership with all its
content and so on it's it's really
something special so I want to be sure
that it lands in the best hands who can
make the most out of it well thank you
very much for your contribution indeed
uh other Grand Masters that have joined
you include uh yesterday it was very
very generous also of Vil
ivanchuk a chess Legend who you had the
great pleasure of crossing swords with
throughout your career uh as he too has
made donation now let me just interrupt
myself and say what is we we've been
just seeing a lot of Trades and it
really looks like Dan's Advantage sorry
to say for Danel fans has completely
evaporated Peter yeah absolutely I mean
that was I was keeping an eye on the
game but I did not want to intercept you
because it was obvious that it's running
towards row and we see two bear Kings at
the end end of the day yeah so a great
defense by hiar one more time but I have
to say that uh when when Daniel missed
this opportunity to go for the opposite
colored Bishop end game I mean middle
game I felt like there is no way you're
GNA win this against Hikaru because he's
just way too good in defending such
unpleasantly seemingly positions but he
is just way too confident and too fast
stubborn indeed and we do have liftoff
of game two uh between Magnus Carlson
and ding Len uh that semi-final is much
tighter as both players have won one set
and they are in this uh pivotal third
Set uh looks like open Sicilians have
become popular in this semi-final Peter
yeah absolutely to our delight and uh
this is this is n n from dingl side I
mean he also used to be famous for
playing E4 E5 and he was brilliant in E4
E5 in the last couple of years but
exactly during this Magnus chess tour I
felt like he he he wanted to use this uh
tour to en his repertoire and en his uh
his his feelings towards openings to to
experience get uh opportunity to to
practice some new possessions and look
at this we are seeing nidorf and magnos
going for Bishop E3 E5 Knight B3 Bishop
E6 Queen D2
mhm oops paron me yeah Queen
D2 Bishop
E7 F3 H5 I mean whenever I see this
position all the memories from the end
of 90s beginning middle of 2000s are
coming on with I face this position with
white with black against topalov
Kasparov vishi I mean all these guys
were real experts and I as a upand
cominging uh young talent I had to get
involved into this position
and whenever I face too kaspo and like
this I knew that I mean this position
can happen and you have to be really
very well
prepared exactly and and just as you you
were describing it there uh the first
time I I mean again I'm old school right
the first time I saw the move H7 H5 you
know I shook my head and I thought you
know that can't be right M obviously is
going to Castle Kingson
and he's going to want that pawn back on
H7 and you know like all you know like
just you know I looked at that move you
know with very very suspicious eyes
slowly over the course of a few years it
became really obvious that the move H7
H5 was completely annoying to players
who like to play the English attack uh
because as Gary Kasparov told me before
his match with short you know the
problem with Nigel short Gary said is
that he plays this English attack with
F3 he's got one idea that idea is to
play G4 the problem is is it's a very
good
idea and H7 H5 really slows white down a
great deal Peter yeah absolutely and I
remember I had a game with Matthew
Sadler who wrote this fascinating book
about the game changer Alpha zero and uh
and I remember that I somehow outplayed
him in this H5 system from the white
side and Out playing man that I somehow
managed to get a small Advantage which
after very precise defense by Matthew
ended in the draw and then I remember
that we went to to analyze we had the
postmortem in tburg it was the tberg
tournament 98 and uh I told him Matthew
but I had the feeling that I was
outplaying you in this part and he said
yeah that's true Peter but you know I
mean I felt like I had so many times
much much worse position that that I got
so he was completely in chilling mode
and he just defended very very nicely
that game that's funny um okay uh set
the table for us Peter what are the
various plans that white can entertain
in terms of how he
should play for an advantage he just
played the move Bishop E2 which by the
way uh wasn't the very first move that
came to my mind but go uh please um
please explain what uh Magnus was
thinking about yeah I mean look at the
clock situation so Magnus had spent
quite some time in the opening not
because he doesn't know this position
simply that he was caught off guard I
mean I'm pretty sure he did not expect
dingly them to probably to play the
nidorf and if play the nidorf use this
very specific variation
and there are all kinds of different
move orders because usually these
positions with H5 used to happen with
the black Bishop on f8 for example here
after Knight B Bishop E6 white goes F3
with the intention of going G4 so black
plays H5 and then one of the most
popular lines from White side is already
here jumping with the Knight to D5 and
it brings completely new Dynamic one of
the ideas is that if black takes with
the Knight on D5 e D5 goes Bishop F5
then you go Bishop d three and after the
trats you capture with the queen in one
go this is already one big big
difference uh especially since this was
not really working out nicely for black
Bishop takes D5 became the main reaction
e takes D5 Knight B D7 and then the big
debate that I was also heavily involved
was in Queen D2 G6 long castles and
Knight B6 one of the crucial crucial
position for for this story and you
already mentioned vasil yanuk donating
also for for this
great great Ka beneficial story and I
immediately remembered that exactly
against vukai had this position and we
had some debate here in our match
mukachevo year 2009 so yeah lot of lot
of memories with all these things but
Magnus chose Bishop D Bishop E2 setup
which probably indicates that he thought
that since the queen is already on D2
and Bishop on E7 he wants to make use of
this I'm not exactly sure that with
Bishop E2 uh you are getting a better
version because black anyway would react
with Bishop E7 it just like choosing
some relatively solid approach right and
also when I see this move Bishop E2 and
Knight bd7 has been played I always you
know like okay these you know somehow
you get infected you get infected with
some kinds of
messages and one of the messages I was
infected with is that when white plays
A3 against the nidorf something went
wrong and you told me that you were
always aspiring to play A3 and the other
message that I got as a youthful player
is that in a sicilian a boleslavsky
sicilian where black has played E5 if
that black could also played d five
without material loss then he's got a
decent game a moment ago I think it was
after the move Bishop E2 um uh Peter
there was an opportunity for black to
play D6
D5 uh but that was not played uh what
was wrong with D5 in your view Peter
yeah D5 I think it plays in White's hand
because uh now after e D5 Knight D5
let's say say I just take everything you
capture with the queen and I even just
exchange I play primitive takes takes go
long Castle I get oops I have to get
used to this yeah very unnatural to move
the king all the way to A1 but yes long
Castle I hit you on D5 with Tempo and if
you move your back the bishop back to E6
I have another Tempo coming with Knight
C5 and I harass you immediately and I
don't think that you will enjoy the
outcome of it no the timing here it
really looks like White's pieces are
jumping into play and the Knight on B8
isn't playing a role so that explains
why ding lren played Knight B8 to D7
yeah and look at this I mean Magnus
managed to fool us as well with his
little move Bishop E2 because it looked
like aha so white is maybe planning to
Castel short but no Magnus just wanted
to somehow make sure that black
clarifies his plan and after Knight B7
he jumped right into the position with
Knight D5 now the move Bishop takes D5
had been played e takes D5 and the
somewhat surprising looking B6 it looks
surprising but actually it's quite a
standard move because black wants to
make sure that the White Knight does not
land on A5 because let's just imagine
black castles which looks more natural
and white goes Knight A5 and you can
never really kick the Knight out because
then the Knight jumps to C6 and then
white gets C4 B4 in and we going to most
probably CC short and enjoy his uh his
position absolutely I remember during
the London match uh well in fact it was
Fabiano playing the white side of these
eses nikov like structures and I
remember you know there was a number of
times that the players were at very
times playing A4 to play A5 and you know
B6 and especially this move B7 B6 I want
to give a shout out to my Grandmaster
friend Nick def firmian nick uh you know
his whole life essentially played the
nidorf and when he got these structures
on the black side he was very good at
setting up B6 A5 and then just planting
a knight on C5 and saying I'm fine uh
Nick was really
outstanding theoretician and wrote In
fact the modern chess openings uh
series but to be honest I have to say
that my feeling is and my experience
tells me in this positions that if white
gets the chance to go Knight D5 and this
bishop D5 e D5 structure appears then
the white King on B1 is much much better
plays than on on G1 really and this is
maybe a little bit surprising but but
the point is that when the white king
gets to G1 uh then black goes for
example short Castle Rook F28 Bishop f8
G6 and prepar some counter play with E5
E4 and actually black is the one who has
the initiative on the king side but when
the white king is on the queen side with
King B1 then whenever black thinks about
castling he has to face the move G2 G4
which can hurt him big time so to be I'm
not liking dingl position at all really
because this move now Bishop
E2 uh begins to really tell as white is
doing his best to discourage short
castles because of G4 interesting I mean
uh the old school is that you always
wanted to go C4 and B4 and A4 and A5 and
bust open the Queens side and you're
suggesting Peter that it's actually a
pretty
nice area for your king just to hang out
the white king is actually perfectly
happy staying on B1 and have we seen the
move B6 B5 by the way yes we see the
move B6 B5 because it is absolutely
Justified now black needs counterplay
with Knight B6 and the move like Knight
A5 now can be answered by Knight B6
hitting the D5 pawn and then we can
again get some very similar positions
that can arise from different move
orders in this position I mean in this
line when white takes on B6 black takes
Queen B6 white goes Knight C6 you go
Rook C8 because you want to make sure
that you kick the knight from C6 with
the idea Knight takes D5 and then the
Knight on C6 is lose and then often the
question can white is white in time to
play C4 and if white is in time to play
C4 with the idea that after B takes C4
you get Bishop takes C4 in then white
keeps the control and look at Black's
King on E8 the bishop on E7 is really
misplaced because if that Bishop would
be on G7 with a Pawn on G6 then any kind
of castles and counter playay with E5 E4
along the long diagonal could happen but
with Bishop on E7 this is not really
doable so this is exactly my feeling
that somehow move pan move it should not
really work out that well for for black
but maybe after Knight A5 he wants to
play Rook C8
first you know uh Peter as you were
speaking it was really going through my
mind that in day one ding Len won a
fantastic game as white in this
structure where just like you were
showing he played C2 C4 and then later
A4 and Bishop takes B5 and he want a
great game is
white Magnus is saying that was such an
impressive lesson that you gave me I
would like to return the favor and it's
kind of surprising uh that the players
are in in uh opposite roles here yeah
but you know one thing that fascinates
Me by with Magnus that you know people
always think that how did he become so
good and uh yes he really became
extremely good but when I think back and
I recall those years like 2004 2005 and
he was just coming up okay it was
already clear that he's fantastic just
coming up is exaggerated he was already
a fantastic player but I was myself top
four five six in the world at that point
playing the world championship match in
2004 uh but I already kept an eye on him
and I kept following Magnus and I do
recall this interview with him from the
World Cup 2005 and they asked him in
this knockout format that what did you
do during your rest in this tourament
and Magnus said well I took with me a
couple of years years of new in chess
magazines and I read the whole issues I
mean basically Magnus during the
tournament went over three four years of
material from new inest magazine with
all the commentary by the best players
at that time and you know if I think
this is also one of his classical
education that he knows how to treat the
positions from the 60s 70s 80s 90s 2000s
he has this total vision about all all
kinds of Chess cultures all kind of
finesses and that's what makes for me A
total package of magnos wow nice story
indeed uh that's kind of scary the fact
that he could take you know volumes of
new and chess magazines and kind of just
like read and absorb them uh I just have
to um boldly point out the obvious that
in the other semi-final also has started
and I see see that you did uh flip to
that uh what do we have here is this the
Rouser lines that we've been seeing from
earlier days of competition Peter yeah
exactly I think that you and Tanya had
been asking the players that somehow the
first day was more sparkling and what
happened and the players switch back to
to those type of uh of lines I mean we
see the the r are happening again in the
games so no more sikov from from dubov M
he might feel that yeah the lower is
maybe not as forening and here he can
get a sharper fight against Hikaru and I
think Hikaru played F3 in that game
actually it happened from a different
move order but they reach this position
it was with F3 but now Hikaru chose King
B1 Bishop E7 F3 a nice little finesse
because if we remember then uh that game
featured FC Knight takes D4 Queen takes
D4 H6 and I was was already mentioning
back then that this is a very special
move order uh black is trying to mix
things up and now it seems like Hikaru
is anticipating Black's
idea let's see what has happened after
King B1 Bishop E7 F3 n Knight takes D4
Queen D4 Queen C7 played H4 played B5
Queen D2 ahuh okay very interesting wow
I I have to say Peter when I see these
top players make these finesse like
moves I think that amateur players are
just like staggered by a move like Queen
D4 to D2 because you know they've read
so many books about getting your pieces
out and putting them on effective
squares and the D4 square at first blush
it suggests that that Queen stands
pretty well and why did he voluntarily
Retreat the queen Peter
yeah the point is that the Knight is
heading to D4 and basically white
already knew that black is anyway going
to push him back uh and we start his
active play on the on the queen side and
you know it's it's very interesting that
uh I was raised in the 90s and I was
witnessing and following so many games
of the of the top players at that moment
and I gathered quite nice knowledge
about all this type of positions and
they used to be my favorite way of
fighting the nidorf or the Rouser this
E4 F3 Pawn structure and I do recall
beating kwana in dresan chess Olympia
the very young Fabiano kwana in this
Rouser variation in a wonderful way but
you know which game I was relying on on
the game Kasparov versus kramnik from
the middle of the of the '90s uh no
actually probably it was not mid it was
already 99 rapid but basically the idea
somewhere Gary used the move Look H1 to
H3 and preparing the move G4 and so on
and it forces black to to play something
like this H6 or H5 somehow the pawn had
to get to H5 and then when the pawn gets
to H5 then there are new Dynamic factors
and so on uh and also V bologan used to
be a very big expert so yeah from all
those games uh I was gathering a lot of
lot of
knowledge uh that story what you were
just saying about the uh Rouser it
reminded me uh there was a tournament
here in Amsterdam and um was it the C
VB
Masters and Kasparov has won uh as white
against Vladimir on the white side of a
Rouser the next morning at breakfast you
know I was kind of commiserating with
with with with Vladimir over his loss
and uh so on and you know the fact that
he was worse in the game and he said
well no no no no I was
better and you know what it is like
Peter to get into those arguments with
those guys you know when they think they
are better you know you just don't want
to go there so I said you know like pass
the
yogurt
it it's opening up a can of worms
speaking of a can of worms uh this was a
type of position that I I remember after
A5 I'm just GNA play a move for white
let's say G4 and I remember there's this
really nice trap that black has to avoid
black has to avoid playing the move D6
D5 because E5 and there's a queen trap
Queen takes and Bishop F4 and uh that I
knew from you know teen teenage Hood uh
that that's just one of the things that
black now has to avoid um but go ahead
take it away uh how would you assess the
SI the current situation and what do you
what would you like uh Hikaru to play if
not G4 by the way yeah you know exactly
I mean those kind of ideas with D5 E5 I
knew like I was like 10 years old and I
was always relying on this concept from
the white side and then I fa Victor
Corno in Dortmund 94 I believe and
Victor played against me the Rouser and
we had some line um I I'm not sure I can
reconstruct but something
like because it was the the the usual
stuff I mean something like this
happened in in our game
[Music]
H you could do it this this
this somehow okay I'm not helping it's
definitely little bit different okay but
the whole point was that I played this
G4 also very proudly with the fact no
the the queen has to be on C7 somehow uh
okay okay just I want to illustrate the
motive G4 D5 I play E5 thank you very
much it's great and Victor hit me with
Knight take G4 F take G4 D4 and was
strategically busted immediately you
know it's not entirely move P move
because here it's something but very
similar and then I understood that oh oh
I mean it's not enough to know one idea
you have to be very very careful yeah
nice night takes I I mean that that's a
snap that will get your attention oh boy
oh boy okay so uh sorry current position
Peter and I see that we've got uh yeah
maybe let's move to the Magnus game some
incredible development very very nice
development I think the right punishment
black is facing and getting because this
this position as we already mentioned
it's it's not the way to to play with
black so Knight A5 Knight B6 takes takes
Knight C6 happened yeah already white is
clearly better and in this type of
positions if white gets a clear better
position it's almost strategically
winning so Bishop d8 C4 takes
castles yeah finally black castles he
had to run with his King away but there
is no Escape because there is already no
safe shelter here for this King Magnus
went luk H E1 Knight D7 G4 buom H G4 fg4
and the move I wanted to highlight is
that after Bishop G Bishop H4 attacking
The Rook on E1 Magnus says you know what
please take this Rook because I need the
dark squar dark squares and Magnus
played the move G4
G5 I really I'm forcibly reminded I'm
actually I'm just doing a a a chessable
course myself winning chess strategies
winning chess tactics and after takes on
E1 uh one of the very very familiar
checkmating patterns Knight E7 check
king h8 queen takes E1 and this idea of
mating with a knight on E7 by taking
away the G8 squares like one of the uh
very important checkm patterns you have
to have in your Arsenal and uh that
I I Magnus did not get an advanced copy
of my
course this looks like it it could be
right out of it and uh my first
impressions is that ding's in really big
trouble uh now uh Peter yeah definitely
but uh ding also played the only move
and the move that that he desperately
needs strategically in this type of
positions the move G7 G6 I mean give
black two Tempo King G7 rook h8 and
black might be fine but those are two
tempies and you are not going to get it
that's for sure exactly so after G6 the
the bishop on H4 kind of looks like a a
sore thumb and the siren Call is to play
Rook E4 and hit the bishop Peter yeah
but if you go Rook e before I might have
Queen F2 or i al yeah I think Queen F2
because Queen might be heading also to
no pardon me I mean it's heading to F5
but it would run into Knight E7
for which would be unfortunate but yeah
it's much more important that with Queen
F2 I hit your queen on D2 and if you
come back to E2 then okay I already then
have the check and I captured the pawn
but even if I would not have that move I
would still have the move Queen F4 so I
think magnos very very wisely made sure
that this F2 square is under control so
the move Rook F1 had been played uh
believe me he's still keeping an eye on
this bishop because he would love to
trap this bishop but he first make sure
that there is no Escape Route via the F2
Square okay so Rook F1 ideas like Rook
F3 Rook H3 or Rook F3 and Rook doubles
on the f file followed by Rook H3 so
that he's basically saying this Bishop
on H4 is ugly it's out of play yeah it's
ugly but you know if the position would
be good and only the bishop would be
ugly I think there would be some more
resources for black my my problem with
this position it feels to me that black
is probably just lost now a move Queen
G4 is not only hitting the bishop on H4
but also hitting the Knight on D7 so how
to avoid how to avoid losing uh material
that's already a very very big question
you know okay so to continue the line
Knight C5 anticipating that we'll be
able to play Rook h8 I don't like it
after Queen
G4 yeah I understand you perfectly
because if you are not getting mated
here I mean it's a miracle if I'm not
getting mated yeah yeah I mean I don't
know it's one of the moves comes to mind
Rook takes F7 yes King F7
but thanks to your knight on C5 you are
at least covering entry points so my
take was actually to give a queen F3
check and you have to run to E8 it's the
only move and then after Queen F6 Rook
H7 Rook F1 I felt like it's it cannot be
noade yeah agreed this has disaster
written all over it uh from the from
from from the early moments that I uh
was was making the suggestion of Knight
C5 it just like closing my eyes to uh
this very nice combination of uh
checkmating patterns Peter yeah exactly
I mean but this is the this is the dream
scenario I think Magnus has a course or
he likes to State always winning I mean
having a attack without sacrificing
anything and it it seems to me like this
is exactly the position that uh that ill
illustrates that that you have a free
attack going and you haven't sacrificed
anything yet you have a very powerful
knight on C6 this bishop on C4 please
don't underestimate it because this
bishop the light squares are crucial
with the Rook on F1 ready to be
sacrificed on F7 uh black has all kinds
of coordination issues with the bishop
on H4 he had to move with the Rook to h8
the queen on B6 actually even if it
would get two extra moves is not easy to
see okay Queen e would be a move but I
mean white has all the time in the world
black seems to be completely busted here
yeah it looks it just looks Dreadful and
uh in anticipation sorry sorry Queen C7
had been played what what does it change
for our Rook takes F7 ideas I think
absolutely nothing I think Rook F7 is a
is a killer blow
uh Ju Just exactly for all of those
reasons and here we you have that move
introducing the queen wow that's that is
uh crushing it feels like yes and then
just Rook F1 right or do you have oh
there is actually Rook H7 I I I
apologize I I haven't seen uh that move
a moment ago could you maybe have gone
Queeny six
o even like this is there not you know
it's funny Peter whenever you really
want to make it beautiful then
something's wrong because like takes E5
D takes E5 D6 check Queen takes E4 oops
uh but you had
um it was really beautiful right up
until that very last moment when we hit
ground uh when we went Queen E6 Che
could we
have ah Rook F1 Tanya wants to get in on
the ction she's she's sensing a
Checkmate brewing and she wants to get
in Tanya
welcome yes your and Peter's instincts
was spot on a big Miss by Magnus with
Rook F3 Rook F7 does win on the spot I
had a look with the engines here it's a
beautiful line let's quickly take a look
before you return to the action King F7
Queen E6 is the correct move King G7 and
now instead of Rook ke instead of Queen
E7 check you have to go Knight to E7
threatening the G6 pawn and this is
extremely difficult for black because
you can't go Knight f8 because of Queen
F6 Queen F7 mate so there's no way to
defend and if you take the bishop on C4
instead yeah simply Queen
G6 King f8 and it stunning Knight F5
with a big threat on G7 E7 and the best
line that the computer gives for defense
is Queen E4 check followed by take the
Knight on F5 and even though it looks
like Black's got Rook into pieces but
just look at the look at the pieces
there's no coordination everything falls
apart Rook F7 would have been game over
on the spot beautiful very very nice
thank you uh very much Tanya that's
that's what we call an educational
moment there Peter uh and I think the
world champion will berate himself he's
very self-critical as Magnus and and
when you got a pretty combination like
that he's going to be upset that he
didn't execute it on the
board yeah definitely but the point is
that this kn7 is really once Tanya
started to to tell the variation that L
F7 is winning and she checked and some
stunning move came Knight E7 jumped
right immediately to my mind but before
you remember we were checking Queen E6
check Queen I mean it looked like there
are all kind of brilliancies and all the
bances were not really leading anywhere
and maybe Magnus F like okay instead of
playing for the gallery let me just
continue in a sensible way because I
don't have so much time and the position
anyway looks very nice all right uh by
the way uh a lot of you are probably
wondering about Julia's bar well they're
a partner with chess 24 Julia's bar is a
Swiss bank that is supporting Rising
Stars as well as
educational initiative so they've teamed
up with Magnus Carlson as a kind of a
sponsor for Kea and every day that
Magnus Carlson wins a set uh Julia's bar
is donating €1,000
EUR uh to Kea benefiting Kea so we just
wanted to make sure that we get out a
big shout out to uh Julia bar for
supporting the tour supporting the
community and uh supporting Kaa so a big
thank you to Julius and thank you to
Tanya for showing us that educational
moment I'm sure Julia's bar is GNA love
that one uh what has happened instead uh
Peter yeah what happens is that Magnus
plays in a very classical natural way
the way usually you love to treat dis
positions only that uh simply he is the
he missed a much bigger chance so all
his moves make perfect sense so he he
played L FC on the other hand he let
dingly them back to the game because
look at this black used his chance
immediately with F5 G takes F6 Knight F6
and another Black Knight is heading
towards the F4 Square Queen G2 Queen D7
first Rook G1 Rook H6 protecting now
white played this very nice little move
A3 typical idea you want to get your
king to A2 move away from all kind of
checks this is a typical idea in this
position that black gets control of many
squares on the on the king side but
actually white doesn't really mind this
because he moves towards the towards the
queen side so Rook B3 had been played
Knight F4 Queen C2 and Magnus probably
wants to invade uh somewhere with uh
somewhere with L B7 yeah sorry to
interrupt you there Peter if you just go
take those moves back that uh Rook F3
right here this exact moment man oh man
I I think a lot of amateur players you
know enjoying your commentary looks at
the moves that Magnus came up with and
said you
know I would never have played those
moves I mean uh I would want to kill
black on the king side so that after
Knight H5 a lot of amateurs would be
thinking I want to Bishop to D3 and I'll
sacrifice an exchange of my Rook if the
Knight came to F4 and because my pieces
are set up on the king side I want to
kill black there and this concept of
just moving the pieces over to the queen
side I think a lot of players would have
just said nope didn't see that one
coming how about for you uh that
flexibility of saying no sometimes I'm
just not going to uh continue my
kingside attack uh and I'm going to
switch that's that's hard uh Peter yeah
maybe it's hard but to me it comes very
natural to be
honest and the point is that throughout
my career maybe I have used those moves
too often even at the moment when it was
not necessary when brutal force would
have maybe won the game but I preferred
you know I know that I need A3 King A2
let me be first safe
and by thinking about safety first I
missed that golden opportunity of
hitting my opponent with a terrible
punch uh so that's why I'm not the best
address for your question because for me
those things come first and once I know
that I have done everything nicely then
I will look for the for the killer punch
very very good okay so we did see after
Knight H5 a complete change of Direction
by Magnus Carlson is suddenly put his
pieces from the king side to the queen
side Rook B3 and he keeps following it
up too uh as you say safety first uh
yeah well it's not just safety first but
simply he also believed because it's
sensible that black had too many pieces
on the king side so there is already no
uh way to to really do something he
might have felt that he had a chance
before but now let's be sensible and he
he liked this plan but I believe that
this move King h8 was was maybe missed
by agos because he felt like okay I have
a nice position let me play quickly I
have my plan King A2 Rook B6 Queen BC
Rook B7 and ionna rim but with King h8
black makes sure that he activates his
queen to queen to F5 kicking away this
queen from C2 and all of a sudden black
is very much alive and those are the
things why the nidol players like the
nidol that whenever you get a counter
chance then you really get a counter
chance and look at this Magnus is down
to 40
seconds anything can happen now as much
as I wanted to get back to the car
Nakamura game I we've got to stay with
this because boy is it heated up and we
just see this move whoa Knight F4 E6
discovered attack against the queen
Peter yeah I mean to be honest I I also
need some time to to orientate I don't
know what is going on uh I'm also not
sure the players know what is going on
it's such moment when you really have to
on your instinct time is sticking done
there you are not a computer you cannot
understand you cannot calculate
everything till the end so very complex
fight it seems like ding is trying to be
safe and he opted for this for this end
game but if he gives Magnus the the
confidence that everything is under
control then maybe Magnus will make the
make use of it
well I was about to say if there's one
thing that every chess player hates is
not only when their King is under attack
but when they're short on the clock and
when your opponent is short on the clock
I don't know about this decision by ding
Lin to rush into an endgame I think that
makes it a lot easier for Magnus to find
his moves now having said that um you
know there is a pass Pawn uh the pass D4
Pawn in the position uh Peter is it a
serious
threat I don't know somehow my feeling
is that this position should be lost for
black uh and Magnus played the move A4
basically showing that yeah I have no
respect for this D3 pa okay actually he
has the respect but the point is that D3
was not a threat because of Rook C3
right and the black pawn cannot go to D2
because Rook takes H3 comes with a check
check that's the reason why King G7 had
been played and after King G7 Magnus
played the move Rook
[Music]
F2 just preparing in in case it's
necessary uh both uh Rook F1 and Bishop
A6 E2 getting out of the way of the path
of the a pawn I'm sorry to say but this
looks like a terrible endgame for ding
Lin suddenly as whes queenside pawns
they're just going to March up the board
maybe just the a pawn will will will do
it itself I don't know Peter this
doesn't feel good for black yeah I have
the feeling that this is this is lost I
mean yeah ding ding had this chance yeah
because Magnus was I think also quite
unhappy with how the game developed and
all of a sudden exactly at the moment he
was done on time and he was not so happy
uh he was presented with this this end
game where he he knows that he is better
for sure I believe he even feels that
this should be winning and the clock is
not an issue anymore exactly and again
for those of you who may be joining us
late uh today is Magnus Carlson
chessable course day you can get a free
endgame Lesson by going to chess.com and
signing up for Magnus Carlson's
uh light touch endgame as he discusses a
very nice endgame in his match believe
it's from 2013
chenai um when he first became world
champion so be sure to uh check out that
free lesson now after this move Rook F2
I noticed that dingler in has suddenly
gone into a deep tank uh Peter and I
think he's just beginning to
realize that his is being
cooked yeah I I have the feeling that
okay with my respect towards D he
somehow felt that this is not going to
work but he he somehow panicked maybe he
felt like he was under so much attack
that he was so relieved that finally he
gets an end game but right exactly at
that moment uh I think he simply carried
too much emotions from what happened
earlier in the game because
otherwise how on Earth would you end up
in this uh practically lost 10 game and
Magnus used the move Bishop F1 of course
a beautiful move a very nice
intermediate move hitting the Rook on H3
Rook H5 Rook G2 and now after Rook takes
D5 Bishop D3 had been played and we all
know what it means absolutely and what
it means is the most gorgeous blockading
Bishop you could possibly have against
doubled D Pawn suddenly this Pawn on D4
the pawn on D6
are tragically blockaded and even the
bishop on E3 as you're pointing out
Peter uh it doesn't play a role in terms
of stopping White's pawns and B2 B4 A5
King B3 it's a coronation there's just
simply no stopping this is gone I mean
this is flat out gone if we could go
back just to the moment where Magnus was
down to 40 seconds ding had played a
sharp move Knight F4 to E6 and as you
said we were just
kind of catching our bearings as right
about here I would say three results
Peter and like five moves later one
result yeah absolutely I mean okay but
but you know I I told you that this kind
of cement on the on the queen side is
also really irritating for for black
because maybe simply ding was panicking
that white simply going to play Rook B4
rook cb3 and then invade the along the B
file and what he will get in return
right but uh but okay still this this
end game and knowing that this end game
you will get against Magnus and Magnus
has already won the game yes uh
absolutely so 96 I think was okay Queen
C2 but now something went seriously
wrong I mean completely off the rails
takes and Knight D4 I think was
unfortunately
uh a step in the wrong direction uh had
had he played Knight maybe to C5 before
the trade of Queens uh occurred Peter
because obviously after Knight C5 if
black can get in Bishop F4 not only is
he defending his King but he's attacking
the pawn on H3 H2 Pardon Me Maybe
getting some endgame chances himself
this feels a lot more
competitive than what happened in the
game yeah to be honest it also feels bad
but yeah the the game had basically
black had zero chance and I feel like
maybe here the The Experience uh the
lack of experience came came to to to C
because ding doesn't have enough
experience in this and when you are done
on time I'm pretty sure a player like
topalo or Kasparov would have handled
this I mean they would get the most out
of this position I don't know what it is
but they would never ever go down
without any fight in this type of
positions but when you are not that
familiar with this then it's very easy
to air especially with little time so uh
yeah great victory for for Magnus but it
also puts nading under lot of lot of
pressure exactly we can't belabor the
point because we've got action in the
other semi-final uh take it away wow uh
end
game I mean dare I say it Peter this
seems to be a day for end games and it's
a day that we're giving away an endgame
course uh I don't know I the stars are
aligned something just happened and
we're getting a lot of educational end
games uh what has happened uh Peter yeah
I think that okay we had a very very
sharp game between the two uh exchanging
blows but uh we have we had mixed missed
the missed the action in between
I don't think that we have the time to
go back and analyze deeply maybe we can
just run over the game but let's not
talk little bit about this end game
because it looks very uh
instructive instructive in the way that
you know it looks like white is a white
is a clean extra healthy Pawn up but I
know from my experience with all these
nid orfs that with this bishop and the
white Pawn on H4 this is always cont
play for black because this bishop F2
idea somewhere later if you trade the
Rooks or you pay too much attention for
action on the queen side will always
disturb you and the question is where to
place this white knight it would be
lovely to go Knight F4 Knight D3 but it
also gives black the chance for example
to put his Bishop on D4 for example if I
do something like this yes it's the it's
the natural way but the question is can
you play for example Rook D4 how to
evaluate this
position okay we are forced to trade
Rooks let's say forced to trade now I'm
setting some Bishop F2 and if you
implement the idea I mentioned then
suddenly Black Goes King E6 King F5 King
G4 and wins the game exactly so how
about King D2 uh in that position after
the trade of Rooks Peter yeah yeah King
D2 okay so I going to play Bishop F2 and
now I get my Tempo just just in time to
stop you from playing King F5 to G4 yep
Knight G2 so King E6 I wanted to meet
with King E2 to stop the the the black
king from coming
straight into my territory yeah I don't
know where I should be putting this
bishop because wherever I put it will
hurt
me that's right yeah very a very uh
tough end game uh you know in one case
you mentioned that the pawn on H4 that's
really an annoying source of counterplay
for for for for black uh and white has
to be careful on the other hand it's
sort of like I don't know this Knight
can maybe go Knight to D5 to E7 and
annoy the G6 Pawn so I think both both
both uh players have issues fighting the
minor piece
yeah but the point and the game actually
ended in a draw
so seen we have seen probably repetition
yeah
because because the players are not
allowed to agree to draw till move 40
okay why H hang on I have to click AO
update often times what I've done uh is
sometimes go to the other game and then
switch back okay you're but somehow
because both games finished the auto
update for some reason didn't auto
update does not work or maybe it just
uh no actually probably it was just just
okay this is not a big mystery that how
did this happen probably Tanya is here
she can she can tell us everything Tanya
what happened we're going to hear on
that shortly but let's not forget that
with every passing game and every draw
that happens in this round for Daniel
Duo of the paths for comeback gets
narrower and narrower so he's still got
two rapid games left uh possibly a tie
break but he's in a must win on demand
situation if he needs the match to keep
going I think the explosive round so far
has been the uh Magnus ding game and
let's just quickly take a look at that
because while you were discussing I had
the opportunity to check out some lines
uh with the engine uh and if we just
back up to that moment when Magnus went
Rook F3 Rook F3 does give away a big big
portion of the advantage things turned
out well for Magnus in the end but he
was he was close to missing out and the
point is that if that would have
happened the world champion would have
kicked himself for missing this huge
opportunity of Rook F7 King F7 let's
just quickly show that line to our
viewers who are joining in right now uh
that he had this brilliant sacrifice
with Queen E6 which you and Yas both saw
uh with your it was just amazing amazing
to hear that because just intuitively
you both felt that this was the right
way to go and it was and here probably
this is what Magnus missed this option
of going Knight E7 and there's no
defense with G6 you can give up another
piece with C4 but it just leads to M
after Queen G6 Knight F5
instead after Rook F3 ding did play the
best moves on the board and managed to
actually come back and bounce back in
the game he had an option to go Rook H5
instead of F5 but F5 is also good and if
you just go to that point that you were
discussing about the queen trade Peter
because I think that was the critical
moment and right about
here indeed yes after Knight E6 Queen
C2 you were on the money with your
suggestion of a move like Knight C5 here
and that was the correct way for ding to
continue and I think it's a really
instructive end game after you take on
e4 the point is that you just win a very
important Tempo with attacking The Rook
on C3 if Rook C two you can go Knight D2
and start advancing the E Pawn and
that's why your counter lies you're also
threatening the H2 Pawn you can give up
the A6 Pawn with this E4 Pawn is what
you're relying on if KN if on Knight C5
white would have gone Rook B6 instead
which is what you were looking at a
really nice but a very difficult to find
find this move on the board Queen to F5
and I think this is a very instructive
moment and a very instructive move
because uh black is threatening to again
go ahead with the E Pawn and if you take
on F5 suddenly the pawn structure for
black works out and the F Pawn will
become strong with F4 and just uh with
with these two pawns just Unstoppable
this was the moment that Ding had to
come back in the game but after trading
the Queens the way he did Magnus was
just all boss and uh as we've seen him
again and again with his peace play and
the way he the way he just gets the
initiative in end games when making All
the Right Moves it feels I think this is
what makes him such a master at these uh
at these in these positions gave Tingler
in absolutely no chance after this and
like he was saying yes what a day it is
to play all these end games because we
are lucky that we have a free lesson on
end games by chessel uh for all of us so
if you're looking at playing like the
world champion these endings and
understanding what it is that separates
him from the rest when it comes to comes
to endings and when how he strategizes
what are the strategies that he uses
it's a it's a course that just gives you
a peak into his mind he analyzes the
brilliant game from the 2013 World
Championship match against wishi Anand
and with all the breakdowns of what it
takes for a masterful play during the
during the most critical part of the
game which is the which is when you know
you've traded off the queens and you
might feel like okay the tactics and
everything is over but really it is it's
still a very very rich portion of the
the game and I think all our trainers
have always told us that if you can get
good at endings you can get so many
points in chess because that's one of
the areas which a lot of people do
ignore so definitely have a look at this
uh uh lesson it's a it's a taste of
what's coming up with the Magnus touch
the entire course of endings of end
games which chessable will be launching
very soon uh this one's a free lesson
you don't want to miss out on it and we
also have because we've got a little
more time let's bring in some of the
conversations that we've been having on
Twitter we had Aron writing in with all
set to watch the Magnus Carlson final
semi-final today between Carlson ding
Nakamura Duba a crucial game for duar
and ding to ret retaliate yes Aon and
ding now playing catchup to Magnus
Carlson one point down Magnus got the
lead in the match with one and a half uh
to half and uh dings got a bounce back
but more importantly dubov time's
running out it could be the very last
day on D in Dub's journey in the Magnus
Carson chess store let's move on to the
next
one we also had not surprised writing in
will blindfold chess ever be added to
the Grand Chester or Magnus Carlson
Chester if current situation doesn't
improve by the next year that is an
interesting suggestion but I have to say
that I think we have enough actions with
I with eyes open uh you know with these
different time formats and with chess
being the very rich and the Beautiful
game that it already is I don't think we
need to go to that level of Madness
where we start including blindfolds but
I think in general blindfold chess as a
separate event uh could be very very
interesting to watch because uh it's
very very challenging but I I think as
far as the tours are concerned it's uh
it's exciting to see these different
time formats come into play and see who
really is the best player with the with
a different situation on the clock uh
maybe we'll get Yas and Peter's view on
this later but let's move on to the next
one we heard from Leon writing in Peter
the bonii chess Legend just made a 1,000
$1,000 donation to chess 24 ska campaign
and said being a part of the Magnus
store has enriched his life over the
last few months and his wonderful
commentary has enriched our lives too
Leon I could not agree more with that I
think I think this entire Magnus Carlson
chest store has been such a boon to all
of us in a very difficult and
challenging time in um
uh it's
uh it's really been a blessing and uh
bought the community together through a
through a stunning game that so many of
us have gotten involved with at
different levels and wanting to improve
and wanting to get better at and a big
shout out to Peter for his very generous
contribution to to Kea as well as to
finding a way to help to help youngsters
in Hungary this is something that he
spoke about and it's just a no-brainer
that when you've got this opportunity to
uh to go premium and to be able to do
something for the community through a
spot that has given us so much uh I
don't know what's stopping anybody from
doing that and we've had some brilliant
uh contributions from from Legends
across chess because it really is it
really is the right time to do something
about about communities that have
suffered and have had a big impact
through chess and K's K's cause is all
about that about helping businesses
entrepreneurs small underserved
communities survive in this very
difficult time so if you've been
contemplating about going premium do not
wait any longer because you can work on
your chest get get so much benefit about
all the benefits with going premium but
also give back to the society what else
we got on Twitter let's take a look we
have have a question for yes and for
Peter uh from Lars writing in Hikaru
used to be known as mostly a great
attacker but seems to have become one of
the most resourceful defenders in later
years some players changed their styles
did the conscious change of style ever
tempt you I think that's a really
interesting question Lars also because
this is something that Peter spoke about
so let me just uh let me get him into
the conversation Peter what do you
what's your take on this well to be
honest uh I had quite a lot of good
positions against
Hikaru and I I knew right from from all
my experience that he's a brilliant
Defender so it does not come as a big
surprise to me that uh he's saving all
these great possessions but clearly I
mean what made him so famous were all
these brilliant attacking games and
people are often fooled by this yeah I
mean in order to be one of the world's
best players it means that you have to
be really Universal of course everybody
has his own characteristics and
definitely Hikaru loves to attack more
than than than to defend but if you want
to be one of the best in the world then
if you have to defend you have to do it
right and taru proves it game after game
that he's completely up to the task if
he's he's asked to do
so well let me just jump in and first of
all say Tanya while you were talking
about Kaa and the donations I saw that
donation bar uh jump once again I think
we're going to cinch the goal that we've
created for ourselves of 50,000 thank
you for your comments we're just going
to let you comment for a couple of hours
and I think we'll reach reach the goal
today in about 90 minutes so you're
doing it just perfectly I was going to
say that uh for me I watched um Hikaru
grow as is a youngster and like all
young proes uh Hikaru was a great
tactician and I think all proes are
great tacticians and then later in life
they develop their own style and at a
certain moment Hikaru said I wanted to
be a great endgame player and in an
interview that he had uh with Jennifer
shahadi he said no no no no don't
compliment me for being a great
tactician a great attacker I actually
really like end games so yeah of course
he's evolved in his style has changed
and thank you very much indeed for the
question Lars um Peter back to you we've
got
liftoff yes we do have lift off Yas and
Peta and before I let you take it away
just a quick update for our viewers
about what happened in that game between
dubab and Hikaru because there is a 40
move rule but unless there a repetition
which did not happen so here's the
update guys uh the players just forgot
about the 40 move rule offered a draw
and it was agreed of course the position
itself is a dead draw they did get a
little scolding from the Orbiter I hear
that did happen but due to practical
circumstances we could not have them
start over from that position again and
given that the position itself was a
draw and just a few moves remaining it
was a draw that's what happened back to
you guys that answers that thank you so
much Tanya and Peter back to you very
nice at the same time I also checked on
my phone I just wanted to understand
whether I'm not getting any auto updates
you know because the game ended or if if
something happened and I know from my
own experience I had a game think
against ivanchuk in the Dresden Olympia
2008 really as you said with with Vil we
had played I don't know over 60 games
throughout our careers and one of them
it was in Dresden Olympics and I also
believe that there was some move rule
but the position was so tense I
completely forgot about it I I had the
white pieces and I offered vilia draw
you know and and he was like shocked
because he even didn't know if he
answers it is it already illegal or not
you know and then while vasil was asking
what is this I also felt myself so
guilty that how could I forgot yeah
really it's it's forbidden it it can
happen there is just way too much
tension and yeah we have the game dingly
and Carson I mean look at this it's it's
the night of Sicilian that's what we
want to see but how did we get here we
got here in a typical Modern Way by
playing one Knight F3 dingl wanted to
make sure that Magnus is not gonna
answer E4 with D5 which worked for him
very nicely yesterday so he played
Knight F3 it feels like ding did not
mind to repeat what happened in the
first game today but Magnus said no and
not interested let me play C5 and dingl
and did not hesitate and went for E4 and
now we are seeing another very sharp
knor wow kind of an English attack as
well um I have the feeling Peter that
you and I after this tournament could
just make a chessable course on the
nidorf and just use the games from the
finals to do it so we will just take all
of our comment
will just double check it with an engine
and we're good to
go yeah well uh actually yeah F3 B5 this
is the this is the main move I mean in
their first encounter when dingly then
shockingly beat Magnus I mean not
because of the result the way he beat
him that was shocking featured the move
H5 which topalo played against me I mean
pardon me if you think like wow why am I
mentioning all this that again I had
some game but but really in this English
attack I mean in the middle of 2000s all
this Vish topal of kaspar and myself
were so heavily involved in all kinds of
discussion that there was almost no
single position we which we did not play
but this H5 move was a big surprise when
topalo played it against me so that's
why I I mention it sure but now Magnus
goes the classic B5 like Kasper and
topalov used to play and here comes this
A3 move which actually was introduced by
Magnus
himself uh not via this specific move
order but he had this game and we are
coming quickly to to that point but let
me just show you this quickly because
Magnus shock the word like year year ago
that he used this move order against the
nidor to get into this H5 type of posss
against Vash gra you know it's it's it's
really fascinating where Modern theor is
developing but uh here we are seeing the
classical approach G4 H6 Queen D2 Knight
B7 long
castles Rook C8 and King B1 so very
typical Sicilian position uh but to be
honest I would say that this is uh this
is the line that white is hoping to get
so I'm very very interesting very
interested to see how Magnus will solve
his opening problems
exactly and Peter uh I mean Way Way Back
even way before me the Caris attack with
G2 G4 against the shanigan Sicilian
opening it terrified everybody and
that's why you've been you know really
harping on the importance of H5 to to
stop white from making this G4 H4 G5
kind of Pawn uh push and uh are you
finding it as surprising as I'm finding
it that Magnus has allowed
it yeah well I mean it it used to be
standard to allow it so this all this
hbd stuff uh with this A3 I you know why
it was shocking for me if we already
talk about this that usually I always
felt like after B5 A3 In This Moment the
move H5 is absolutely Justified because
white committed himself to the little
move A3 yeah and that's why I felt quite
surprising when black started playing H5
without white doing any concession yet
yeah but once you play the move B5 a
then already all these H5 things are
absolutely possible but Magnus probably
wants to keep a completely different
Dynamic and Magnus goes along the
classical main way Rook C8 King B1 D5
played
and now I I peaked ahead and I saw he
played the move D6 D5 Peter yes D5 E5
Knight D5 Knight takes D5 Bishop D5 this
is the absolute classical way how it was
always meant to to deal with this
positions from the from the black side
right and in this sense I have to
actually mention that instead of King B1
I believe that H4 used to be the main
move here
the idea that if you play D5 then I have
Rook G1 and after d takes C4 I can go
G5 right exactly thank you so much Peter
because you're you're triggering a
memory and if you take back the move
Rook G1 for a moment just for maybe it
was your one of your games where you
played like Bishop
H3 with the idea going G5 and Bishop
takes
E6 yeah I think that was the vishy
against halif man something like this
where v v she hit somebody with Bishop
take C6 right and but but I believe that
those positions were without A3 because
here you lost the tempo for A3 and that
was with A3 I mean without A3 with black
playing some B5 B4 because even there
was some moment when Bishop HC was
answered by G5 you know it was I think
99 Linares when all these kind of things
were absolutely normal and it featured
in the game between Anand and Kasparov
uh but uh I'm I believe that those
positions were without A3 okay thank you
for that
clarification ah yes if already we
mentioned it then let me just show you
because I think I can somehow
reconstruct that something like this
used to be the move order back then what
we have been
debating and
H4 B4 Knight
A4 uh and instead of Knight A4 Knight B1
used to be the old move in in
1990 uh and after D5 Bishop H3 G5 I
think this was the game Anan kaspo which
was like a very big sensation back then
age takes g h takes G Bishop take G5 and
somewhere gy played the big new Concepts
some Queen B6 and he was very proud of
it and it solved all the issue for black
in this line exactly I remember him in
new and chess talking about the power of
the on B4 in restraining White's uh
queenside majority uh the current
position Peter is this uh heavy
theoretical territory or are we um
Pioneers no not really because I believe
that this position was somehow
considered to be fine for black and uh
the line with A3 uh never got that
popular in the middle of 2000 because
simply uh still some extra ideas were
not yet known which new computer have
brought new impulse for for white and
that's why it turned out that it is even
more richer than we we s back then and
uh it it comes to my mind as
if I might had a game in Dubai Grand
Prix F Grand Prix rapid in the blitz TI
break against topalo in something like
this and uh and even against Gund in
Monaco and against some of this type
maybe something was different but some
move like Knight E5 hit me very
unpleasantly maybe bodies played it
against me and all of a sudden he hit
the pawn on FC he was coming with Knight
C4 and uh but but but I'm not EXA
everything looks so similar but I I'm
not sure it was like 15 years ago right
Peter by the way uh you are amazing our
audience with with your recall your
memory of the games that you've played
in your career You' made Dresden Boral
and just now uh and all of these names
topof Gasparov and so forth and so on um
do you consider yourself to have an
extraordinary memory and if so why or
did you try to train yourself how do you
remember so well your games because
everybody who's watching this who's any
kind of a chess player is sitting there
saying to themselves wow I I'm jealous
of Peter's
memory oh well it's a good question to
be honest I always felt that I have very
good memory but I would say that I never
trained it but the way I train chess
automatically forces me to to go in this
direction yeah because I always work
very seriously on my openings and it's
not just my games in fact I often
remember much better other people's
games everything what is related to my
own repto and so on comes very natural
for me basically I also feel that if I
close my eyes I can just tell you every
single development from the middle of
90s what has happened and which engine
at which point influenced which decision
and how the theory developed in all
these lines with fit three fit five
later fit seven eight and then we lip
appeared de junor and all these things
and I'm pretty sure if you ask Wishy he
will answer you exactly the same way
because we also used to be training a
lot with vishi together in already in
the from 96 till like
99 and uh I learned so much from vishy
in this sense you're terrifying me Tanya
welcome back uh what's going on hey yes
hey Peter so you guys were talking all
about sty FES and play and I just had to
jump in with something interesting that
came up on our chess 24 chat and it was
shout out to dogok Aslan I'm sorry if
I'm not pronouncing the name correctly
but he says that I love it when a
character of a person matches their
chest style and he gives Peter's example
as well as Gary and I think this is
really interesting because uh you can
think of so many players like that whe
whether it was carpov uh you know his
personality and the chess he got to the
board even vishy even you know with his
in general he's known to be this uh uh
his Universal Style Just matches how he
is as well and you know being positional
but also also being able to play
attacking chess really well and he has
this wi interest in everything maybe not
the best example but you get what I'm
saying and with Magnus we've seen that
as well with dingler and being Hikaru
Nakamura dubov all the personalities
seem to be exactly what they're bringing
on to the board and uh uh it gets that
whole does chess imitate life life
imitate chess conversation so I just uh
I think it was a really interesting uh
point in chat what do you guys think
absolutely I think that uh chess players
their personalities do shine through
mostly sometimes however you get fooled
and Tanya the one player that fooled me
the most was David brunin David was this
quiet the old man who looked like his
greatest love in life was
accounting and underneath this
unassuming dra Garb was this absolutely
vicious attacking
Beast was like like like David this
beautiful innocent accountant like I'm
telling you he just loved to attack so
that was one where boy did I get it
wrong I don't know Peter who for you uh
after you met him and spoke with him uh
did you get this feeling like okay at
the chessboard his character is
completely different from his
personality well I mean usually I would
say that VY when he gets the attack
because yeah he's such a friendly person
you know and it's such a nice uh to to
be next to to him and talk to him chat
with him and if he's not attacking he
seems to be also very polite over the
board he plays very nice accurate chess
and so on but when he gets a chance to
attack he just jumps on you with such
brutal force and he comes up with such
brilliant ideas almost instantly yeah
he's not even hesitating he just comes
with the flow from him that you already
feel at that moment that there is no
mercy and There Is No
Escape nice nice story let's get back to
the action uh dingler and Magnus Carlson
we have developments you saw the move F4
Peter take us through it what's
happening yeah I think that even before
we jump to the positions We we forgot to
mention that basically I mean uh dingan
is fighting today for his life because
it's his last wide game so if he really
wants to equalize the score and this we
see on his approach to the game he's
going for the sharpest position possible
uh he needs to win because there is no
guarantee and probably also no chance to
to beating Magnus On Demand with the
black pieces so what he is doing is
absolutely right uh and as already we
heard this tweet from Ian sov also one
of the true masters of attack and
someone who who knows how to use the
initiative perfectly I mean uh ding
needs to sharpen things up and this is
exactly the type of position he needs
now exactly okay he's got this very
sharp position Bishop D3 on the board
it's very clear that uh he wants Magnus
to Castle kingside so that he could play
G4 G5 and blast open the kingside Magnus
is not castling kingside anytime soon he
delayed it with the move Queen C7 makes
a lot of sense um but from ding's point
of view I mean like you say he's got to
win with white does he press the action
with G5 now or does he still have to
make a safety move or two on the queen
side Peter yeah I mean this last move
from Magnus queen7 was a very very smart
move because uh it looks like a little
move which does almost nothing to the
position but first of all it gets out of
some pin but secondly not only doing
some business on the C file it also eyes
the H2 pawn and this Pawn is very very
important when we talk about the crucial
advance of G4 G5 because thanks to not
castling after H take G5 F take G5 which
would be very unpleasant for black to
deal with black might have the counter
strike with Rook takes H2 hitting the
queen with a
Tempo I just had to stop there sorry uh
Peter because you want to take exactly I
just wanted to make sure there's no
genius Queen sacrifice but yes uh uh
your your point your point is well taken
on how the queen on C7 Sur surprisingly
xrays all the way to
H2 yeah I mean of course it's such a
sharp position we we cannot really uh
evaluate it immediately but this this
was one of my first thoughts and why
does not want to does not really want to
go G5 AG Rook G5 because it feels like
the Black Knight on F6 is just a very
very powerful piece controlling the
center having access to the E4 square
and so on and also damaging the pawn
structure unless you are made
immediately Rook G5 is not what you want
one of the questions that come to mind
does white have time just to play a
simple move like H4 yeah because after
H4 G4 G5 is a very very powerful threat
absolutely I I like that move a lot uh
also what I was questioning is you know
just because the the the queen side and
wherever your king is you can never get
enough safety I was thinking does C3
also make some sense so that after
Knight E4 I could potentially go Queen
C2 uh
Peter yes CC was also one of my uh first
thoughts if I was thinking about how to
stabilize the position but I F like
maybe the audience is already fed up
that I always want to stabilize so why
why is Peter not attacking why is he not
even thinking about attacking yeah so
that was the reason why I decided not to
mention the move C2
C3 I I will I will play the guilty role
in this case I'm happy to say that I too
was thinking Safety First with C3 so
that Queen C2 but your move H2 H4 is
definitely uh a very sharp yeah but the
move like H4 somehow invites the move
Knight E4 and after Queen E1 there might
be some strike like Bishop takes A3 and
if you capture B takes A3 some Knight L
check is coming and I don't know it
looks uh looks a bit scary absolutely
very very dangerous sacrifice indeed
yeah and this comes to mind especially
because dink has played the prophylactic
move Queen E1 and I like this move a lot
especially because it it's also
aesthetical yeah Black's last move was a
nice little fine touch with Queen C7 and
you you do almost the same side stepping
with Queen E1 and tell your opponent
okay please show me are you you really
jumping on e4 uh how you going to deal
with G4 G5 and where is your counter
play yeah it it it makes a a geometric
impression all right and it also
introduces the KN F5 concept I seem to
recall once again I mean you mentioned
it yourself you were in a lot of uh
fights of uh these systems and I I have
it in mind gosh
was maybe the candidates tournament
where was it that you've
played um where you you you were setting
up for a knight F5 was it gosh I think I
was setting up for Knight F5 in many of
my POS games but I never really got
there you saw the games of Michael to
you wanted to imitate him but you never
somehow got the knights to D5 and F5
yeah somehow this half little Tempo that
I was telling you about stabilizing
first was taking it away from me I see
uh the other reason that Queen E1 makes
a nice impression you just showed a
variation uh a handsome one with Rook
takes H2 and by Sid stepping that you
reintroduce the idea of G5 once again
exactly and magnos taking his time look
at this we even forgot to mention Magnus
done to 5 minutes so he's completely out
of his comfort zone and I wonder you
remember yesterday he was mentioning
that he decided that after E4 he will
play something sensible with E5 then
what will he tell us about this game if
it goes wrong exactly uh pointing uh
boldly pointing out a a an opportunity
for Magnus to go really wrong if he
could get his hand caught in the cookie
jar if he tries to take on F4
Peter yeah it's it's a move that
I mean Bishop takes D4 Bishop D4 Queen
takes F4 comes to mind but it feels
somehow that it's it's wrong right
Bishop E5 and there's a queen trap after
Queen
F3 okay you can still maybe go to A4 but
it looks very ugly exactly this is uh
again getting caught at the cookie jar
Queen G5 would have walked into H4 Queen
F3 would have walked into Rook G3 and
that was why Peter had to go uh all the
way across the board to A4 and uh I
don't think anybody would
want to do anything with Black's
position here sort of like uh nobody
signing up for this position as black
Peter yeah absolutely I mean okay now
white has all the time in the world with
this powerful Bishop attacking also
defending back if suddenly necessary if
black all of a sudden gets some
counterplay Also let's not forget that
white G4 G5 plan even he exists but
maybe since I'm not in a hurry I can
even just uh prepare it with with
something I mean I don't see a direct
blow because I would really love to use
this spin uh but I I cannot really get
to to this bishop one of the ideas was
something like takes takes and then
Bishop
G6 but it doesn't work for many reasons
first of all you can even just take and
you hit me on to we check oops and
besides also allowing some moves like
Queen C4 you just don't want to do that
so unless Bishop takes F6 wins on the
spot you even don't consider it exactly
uh as Magnus uh is burning a lot of
clock uh let's just take a quick Gander
at the other uh semi-final game and
again uh dubo in Real uh need of some
wins Peter
yeah it it went along the same ways like
the first game in their match today with
BC Bishop B2 Rook C1 and Hikaru was the
first to to deviate with Bishop F5 not
allowing Knight E4 because that game was
Bishop f8 Knight E4 right and hear went
Bishop F5 after this it became very very
positional everything because white is
lacking some ideas DC Queen D7 so
small
small hesitation okay some offer of
repetition but of course I mean it's not
an option for uh
Daniel so the game continued and this is
very very important that when black
gives up his dusk with Bishop he wants
to make sure that he exchanges the other
one as well as we already spoke
yesterday or somewhere that you you want
to uh exchange your opponents uh pair of
Bishops as quickly as possible you might
not get another
chance
aha this is a very important moment
because with
B4 uh White makes sure that he finally
Advance this is very desirable to to get
B4 now black cannot take on B4 because
of Queen B check but uh I think Hikaru
is already having in mind some set up
and he just wants stability and look at
this he's bringing back the queen
bringing the Rook to d8 bringing the
Knight to D5 this is one of the key
concepts of Black's position in this
whole variation The Rook comes back now
white is just more move away of Landing
the Knight on C5 but black is able to
play B6 and why he's able to do so
because he managed to exchange the the
white Bishop from G2 so all those light
squares are not anymore uh weak really
weakened and uh he's planning to go
Knight D4 and this is how we reach the
position that we just
saw I
see and V grabbed the Pawn King
h8 Queen takes A6 so I wonder if it was
some Force sequence yeah
yeah well he's definitely asking the San
question he's got to win the game as
we've been pointing out he does Trail in
the match two sets to nil he'll have to
win three in a row as Tanya mentioned at
the opening uh of our broadcast today
and by the way I just wanted to say that
uh this has been the single most
successful series of tournaments that
chess 24 has ever uh held and broadcast
and uh you guys are the guilty ones uh
thank you so much for joining us and um
well um making it possible uh without
your support without your being here pet
Peter and I would not be uh doing the
commentary that we are currently doing
after Rook A8 Peter what's going on yeah
I guess that white will rely on some
some move like Queen B5 I mean I want to
understand because you remember I told
you that white took a pawn and black
sacrificed this PA but after Rook E8 now
I'm not even sure if it was a sacrifice
but if it was not sacrificed then then
what it is exactly I mean who is
benefiting from from taking this Pawn
the way I I think Danel is thinking is
that the Rook on d8 defended the pawn on
D4 okay I'm just trying to put the
tactic together yes Queen C4 Rook A3
F4 yeah yeah exactly that was also the
point I saw why Hikaru moved the king to
h8 before because he wanted to make sure
to have some tactical possibilities and
yeah Queen C4 Rook takes A3 on the board
let's see the the clock situation 8
minutes for Daniel 5 and a half minutes
for Hikaru yeah this is a critical
moment I mean if white can't play F4
black is perfectly fine everything
depends on this move yeah exactly that
was my my my thinking as well because
otherwise white has no interest in just
trading off the a pawn and activating
Black's Rook for free he's trying to
punish Black's Rook for no longer uh
defending the pawn on D4 and that was
why F4 came to uh my mind because you
don't play Queen takes A6 otherwise if
you don't have an answer for Rook
A8 yeah exactly and I'm I'm trying yeah
and F4 played very interesting because
then at least we will get an answer to
this
question exactly and as uh Hikaru has to
has to find an answer let's just check
back in on that dingler in game because
I got to tell you I mean Peter after all
of the efforts we made to try to
understand the position I'm
fascinated yeah and look at the clocks I
mean Magnus is done to two and a half
minutes but dingl is not catching him
back and just little bit over three
minutes I mean this is a completely
crazy position and with almost no time
on the clock this this is now like a
blitz fight exactly now one of the
reasons we played F4 is not only the
play
G5 but in some cases we wanted to play
the move F5 and potentially undermine
the support of the bishop on D5 so Peter
is F4
F5 uh
on uh White's
agenda yeah it it is I mean definitely
it is I mean F4 F5 is is one of the main
ideas but uh I don't know if we should
discuss it or not because exactly at
this moment I see that dingl has chosen
H4 move okay let's not discuss it
because doubtlessly any discussion of
the position after F5 is going to be a
very deep convoluted one the players are
down to two minutes for Magnus and three
minutes again they get 10c bonus for
each move they execute H4
Peter yeah I mean okay
H4 it seems like if there is nothing
black can do you remember I mentioned
this idea of Bishop takes a I just
mentioned it as an idea because I did
not really believe that it's it's
working white has too many different
options and the black king is still in
the center so somehow the the feeling is
that it it should not work and Magnus
played the move Queen
B7 indicating first of all that he keeps
an eye on the E4 Knight so extra support
and there some ideas B5 B4 because the
queen is supporting right and this
exactly brings me to to this uh what we
discussed about this C move you remember
we had this question about C3 then maybe
Black's reaction would anyway be Knight
E4 Queen C2 and queen
B7 supporting the Knight and hinting at
some Bishop takes A3 ideas
gotcha makes makes perfectly logical
sense to me
uh Peter but Queen B7 I mean it's like
neither player is is backing off I mean
uh each player is I is calling the pot
so to speak I mean uh this is a great
game yeah absolutely and with all all at
stake I mean it's uh it's incredible I
mean one and a half minutes for Magnus 2
minutes 8 seconds for dingl and we see
CLE Bishop takes a played C3 on the
board a move that we wanted to put when
our Queen was going to C2 but Bishop
takes A3 now because there was no more
B4 there was no A4 for black A5 for
black in the position the B5 Pawn is
saying black does not want to Castle
kingside I mean he's basically whoops so
I can't go kingside I can't play
A5 I've got no other play except the
sacrifice and he's done it
Tanya
he has done it blitzed it out and um C3
in fact the computer gives it as a
horrendous move just and I'm not sure if
ding actually missed it the computer
liked White's position instead of C3 it
recommends Knight B3 but look at look at
the Players now Magnus also was
surprised to see C3 on the board and
immediately bit Blitz out Bishop A3
let's not forget ding Len is chasing the
score and you can see it on the camera
that he realizes that something's gone
wrong he has played the move f five and
with a minute and a half on the clock uh
I really think that Ding has mess this
up at the moment at least the computers
are giving a big advantage to Black and
Tanya just that You' joined us after F5
the recommended engine move would
be B4
wow Magnus I'm not sure if Tanya agrees
with that
wow now that is really doubling down on
the action I
mean okay this is this is impressive
stuff uh Peter take it away do your best
uh we won't hold you to it because uh I
think the players are really feeling
nervous at this
moment yes F5 had to be played it was
the only way but but still Black's doing
really well off the bishop A3 and Magnus
blitzing out I don't know how these
these guys do it in seconds again the
best move according to the engine B4 and
get this now if ding wants to stay in
the game he has to go C4 CB4 Bishop B4
is game over because of the pin along
the B file you don't want to open that
with threats of Knight C3 and the queen
attack this would be disaster I am
expecting ding to go C4 the advantage
has shifted to uh to Magnus and I'm
looking at him on the screen he looks
extremely confident right now exactly
thank you Tanya that moves 4 a
indication indeed that Ding has let
things slip you talk Peter yourself
about vishy what a polite hospitable
generous kind person he is and then
suddenly he goes into beast mode I've
got a feeling that uh right now after
that day one result most especially
Magnus is all
business yeah I mean this C4 had been
played nicly check followed King A1
this looks very very bad for for white
and you know I had this thoughts in my
mind that when the time trouble phase is
approaching and we have this very very
sharp typical but sharp position in the
night of Sicilian where dingan doesn't
have enough experience I felt that
something might go wrong for him because
I know exactly that uh intuition plays
such a big role and there's a def for
Knight F3 player I mean if he has time
because he's such a great player and so
strong he can navigate but uh the
instincts are are not not there they
they simply cannot be there because uh
you haven't played enough you you
haven't played enough games you haven't
analyzed enough of such positions and
Magnus on the other hand from White and
from the black side has more experience
in this type of positions well you
you've touched on something that uh I
mean has kept me in a great deal of
astonishment and that is that the
players today today's top players uh are
ambidextrious they can play E4 and D4
and in my day uh the players really
specialized I mean Bobby fiser was an E4
player for example and a players just
kept their repertoire but today's
players seem to be capable of playing
everything and I mean from E4 E5 to open
Sicilian to you name it they're ready to
contest and yet just as you're saying
because they don't have the great feel
uh experience knowledge their instincts
sometimes lead them astray uh dingin is
not what you
call a die in the wool one E4 player and
maybe these nidorf positions where
instinct is so necessary Peter it's hard
for him
to play yeah absolutely I mean it's it's
hard for anyone who who doesn't have the
experience I remember that in all these
L tournaments when I fac Gary and I had
good preparation of course he also had
great preparation but I managed to put
him for example under pressure and uh I
had things under control but whenever
the time was ticking done then Gary
always outplayed me with one minute each
on the clock you know and uh that that
feel that you know I was very good at
those positions but G was even stronger
yeah
and this this this this experience okay
in such positions anyway Gary is
probably the best in the world or was
the best in the world because as Gary
said in the broadcast himself no no no
no no uh I mean of course the modern
players are so good so on but if it
comes to to to the feeling to the
intuition then I still believe that GAR
is the best in this night of positions
wonderful we do have a lot of moves uh I
noticed that uh well I mean Magnus has
sacrificed a piece and he's just played
this I it looks to my eyes like a
cruncher of a move uh Rook B4 Peter uh
Queen takes B3 is on tap uh dingler in
should he lose this game will'll lose
the set yeah he actually designed
already so it's over yeah I yeah Rook B
before just clinches it and and that's
it but to be honest once this Bishop
takes a B4 happened and Tanya confirmed
that computer also thinks that this is
just winning for black then it was clear
that it's game over because magnusv
never let this
sleep wow our congratulations there as
Magnus smashes through on the queen side
we have one game going on Danel and
hearu uh for those of you watching get
your questions ready send them onwards
to Tanya as we anticipate
the world champion Magnus Carlson
joining us in a short while uh what do
you have for
us I just saw this move Knight B2 uh I
thought I thought it was forking Rook
sorry uh what do you have for
us um Peter about this game yeah I mean
if you just go back to to this F4 I feel
like Hikaru had an incredible overview
of the position because he he did not
panic because it was all part of his
plan he knew exactly that yes I lost
this Pawn on D4 but white is lacking
some coordination he just made a move
little move H6 and this move shows
confidence because after B5 he plays
Rook B3 and somehow he understood that
there is no way white GNA be able to
stabilize the position it seems like
Rook C6 come Rook C6 comes in the tempo
white is tempy up I mean Pawn up plus
Rook C6 com with the tempo but Hikaru
has everything under control just little
move Queen F7 Knight CC Knight B4 and
that's how all this dance with the forks
started uh I mean also Daniel was doing
everything I mean queen C4 Queen takes
C4 Rook C4 Knight takes DC Rook D1
Knight B2 another move Rook E4 was
played a very stylish great move getting
out of this fork in an elegant way so
Rook takes E4 Rook d8 check King H7
Knight takes E4 play then this is the
current position that we have on the
board I tell you I don't understand it
Peter in day one we didn't see hardly
any endings we just saw a lot of blows
now it's endgame day endgame day is what
it what we came in with as uh chessable
made a very nice announcement that they
are giving a chessable course on the
endgame delivered by none other than
Magnus Carlson himself for free so you
can go to their site and download the
endgame Tanya what do you have for us
we've got Magnus Carlson and Tanya
welcome to you both we do have world
champion Magnus joining us uh
congratulations on today's win
Magnus thank
you uh today again wrapping up the match
in uh in three games in a dominating
style but a very very different kind of
chest from what we saw
yesterday yeah for sure um we both
decided to go for open Sicilians today
and uh that sets the tone right then
it's inevitably going to be going to be
pretty fighting
um but
um yeah um I guess both games could have
gone either way but um I'm happy to
happy to Prevail um and think as I was
better most of the first game I think
it's it's fair enough Magnus we are
going to get into details about your
match bit because there is this very um
exciting game going on and Daniel is in
a must-win situation in his match let's
let's get your thoughts on that first if
that's okay with you
um yeah
um first of all I think white cannot
force a draw with uh
with F5 King G8 rook d8 and so on you
escape with the King and if white cannot
force a draw I guess he's in uh he's
probably in serious
[Music]
trouble so so yeah I think he's in
serious
trouble do you do you think it's uh it
is Hikaru who's going to be in the
finals that would not be really be a
brave uh guess would
it that is true not at this point um all
right but um what do you think you've
have you been keeping an eye out on this
uh on this semifinal bracket as well
while your games have been on between
Daniel and Hikaru and what do you think
went wrong for Daniel in this
match
um I think the first match he had every
chance to to
win um
yesterday
you know yesterday he had serious
chances to win in this in the second
game but overall I think uh car was a
bit better yesterday so I guess after he
got a good start in the first day then
he just been been been better um I mean
there's there's not all that much else
to to say but let's see if he can if he
can find a way to to fight and uh and
perhaps draw this
game yeah it did look like Hikaru was
dominating this entire semi-final match
and and to me it felt like on day one
that game two I don't know if you saw
that when he went King E7 and lost on
Queen G7 uh lost after Queen G7 it felt
like that was the turning point for this
semi-final match because after that just
Hikaru seemed
Unstoppable yeah I I think in hindsight
that's um very a very easy uh moment to
to pinpoint ever since it's been it's
been downhill for for
Daniel all right I think actually this
particular choice by iaru I'm not 100%
convinced about because I'm
not I'm not that sure about the Rook
ending in The Rook ending there could be
some some chances for for white so I'm
not really sure about this whole Knight
Al also you don't even have to exchange
CH actually you can go rook d8 and then
Knight G3 or rook d8 and Knight C3
probably is is
better okay so we goes King
F3 um sort of same
uh same
idea yeah of course if I I were to to
bet I would say that car would win the
game but it's it's not it's not
clearcut and Magnus according to you
between these two players Hikaru and
Daniel in uh in the blitz format who do
you think is a stronger
favorite I think is is uh is probably
slightly better in in Rapid and then
significantly better in in Blitz I mean
Dan is a very very strong Blitz player
but your car is uh uh car is I think
even better all right so this position
we can term it as um playing for two
results for black and that's a pretty
good situation for Hikaru to be
in yeah Knight F2 that's probably clever
he wants to reroute the Knight to to
G4 and and that's one of the reasons why
I'm as I said earlier I'm not really
convinced that the
maneuver uh of of the Black Knight to C5
really achieved all that much
okay and while we wait for this uh this
game to go on I want to talk about uh
game two from your from your match
because I think that was that was a real
blow up of a game firstly were you
expecting ding to go for the night off
today oh not at all uh I was I was
expecting him to continue with the with
the Berlin as he has for for most of uh
most of these online tournaments so that
definitely came as a as a
surprise and then you slowed down a
little bit when he went H5 what were you
thinking uh at this moment
um I don't know I was thinking of
different move orders and uh exactly how
it's going to
play that's yeah that's right
now sorry I just I thought you were you
had a smile when you were looking at the
H5 move and I was wondering if you were
thinking about something about the game
oh no no it's it's uh I I just noticed
that uh iar actually played H5 at almost
the exact same moment that was the thing
all right at the same
moment yeah no but I I think in general
um ding played the the opening uh
inaccurately and I was significantly
better after after after the opening but
then of course at some point he got back
in the game and um I don't know we got
an ending that should have been kind of
equal uh and then I I just suddenly won
it so yeah we want to talk about this
moment Magnus here you played Rook F3
did you consider Rook F7 here obviously
uh that's what I spent my time looking
at but I just felt that my position was
so good that
um there was no reason to to go for it
unless I was sure it was winning so one
line I was considering here was check uh
King G7 and then Queen E7 followed by
Knight
E5 um and I felt as though if
D5 Bishop B3 I'm probably significantly
better um there are lines like Rook H7
and also Queen B7 intending to take the
bishop on B3
um but they both
looked um pretty great for um for
white
um but I was not so sure what happened
if he he's gone Rook um if he goes Rook
H7 instead of uh instead of Knight um
instead of
D5 um and and so I I understood that
knight7 was winning somehow uh but I
didn't see it there either like 97 he
goes Rook H7 and then I just wasn't
sure probably Rook F1 wins that's
the probably that's the
thing right yes the computer gave a big
Advantage with Rook F7 and this Knight
E7 line and um so after playing Rook F3
there was a big shift in the evaluation
and obviously this is all engine stuff
uh did you you still felt that you were
doing doing well at this point oh yeah I
felt that I was still significantly
better here um but I think afterwards it
sort of
[Music]
uh sort of fell fell a bit apart by the
way Nar car is completely winning so
yeah this looks totally lost no
yeah yeah wow so that would mean Daniel
duo in big trouble uh all right let's
get back to let's get back to your game
because we do have the lightboard on and
it looks like black is doing very very
well here so in that uh in your second
game just if you can have that position
up right about here you suddenly shifted
your entire play to the queen side and U
from being very aggressive playing
towards uh the other side of the board
and then black somehow stabilized did
you have the feeling that something's
gone wrong or were you still uh feeling
good about your position around here no
uh I was feeling good all the way until
he played Bishop G5 which I missed
okay and then I thought it was just a
mess yeah he did have this chance to go
Knight E6 and Knight C5 but I think he
just made a really big mistake when he
uh when he traded and this ending is
just really bad for black for for black
yeah uh that is that is probably correct
um yeah I guess I guess here here he uh
he he would have been fine but um but I
think what I I did there move 45 Rook F2
and then mishop F1 that was really
really
important um and that sort of kills it
because otherwise he would have had
serious counterplay with D3 but here I'm
just in time um to consolidate and then
my pawns just
run right and then the next game um both
of you were taking a lot of time in the
opening uh Magnus and suddenly C3 on the
board tell us what happened before C3
what what were you completely out of
prep because a lot of time had been
burnt by
now yeah he didn't really play what I
expected there in the opening and it's
um I feel like it's a position where
black must be fine but he clearly had
looked at it at least somewhat and um I
mean I'm not the night of specialist at
all so that kind of makes it makes it
more difficult yeah um right uh and so I
mean I I spend a lot of spend a lot of
time but I I couldn't
really couldn't really figure it all out
but I felt that I made one really really
really big
mistake
um here um yeah Queen C7 I think was
okay Queen
E1 um Knight E4 Knight E4 then of course
he can he take he can take on E6 and
then take on e4 but I felt that this
sort of ending was was
defensible right
uh uh and
um yeah so he went to H4 which of course
surprised me a little bit and queen B7
was just really really bad
um that was um yeah that was that was
that was not good at all
but then he returned the favor instantly
by going C3 um did you do you think that
was just an oversight missing Bishop A3
completely I have no idea what he was
thinking because I mean immediately
after I made the move I realized he has
Knight B3 and I think I'm just
lost um if for instance Bishop E3 Queen
E3 I I have no
counterplay and also if I move the the
bishop he has he has Bishop D4 and he
probably just wents so that was that was
really really bad uh and that's where
the game just turned on on one move I
think right and uh with that uh you've
taken a 2-1 lead in the match starting
the match playing catch up then you won
two sets in a row what's your take on
this entire best of five longer match
format and just a quick update for our
viewers that we do have a result um
hekar Nakamura did win that end game and
which means Daniel dubov to have any
hope of continuing the tournament he has
to win the next game on demand and take
it to the tie break because Daniel is
playing catch up for two sets if aaru
Nakamura wins today he goes into the
finals uh Magnus what's your take on
this five five uh set of five format
which is longer than what we've seen on
the tour
previously I think for the final it's
it's fitting that we have uh we have
more matches and more more chest so I
think it's great it's great but you
would have been in was it best of
three well we'll see maybe I'll be in
with the best of five as well all right
we're GNA wish you all the best for that
and I'm gonna hand it over to Yas and
Peter if they've got any questions for
you thank you and congratulations thank
you absolutely uh thank you Tanya been
chomping at the bit there a bit uh
Magnus uh we have been extoling the fact
that you have an endgame a chessable
endgame that we're going to be giving
away to for free to everybody who signs
up for it and I like to say about myself
that no matter how badly I teach I
always learn
something what did you learn about the
chessable endgame that people can get
for
free
um I learned I learned for ones that I
used to be extremely
stubborn and now you became flexible or
what no I I think uh it's it was a good
thing extreme extreme stubbornness in
trying to to to win games right um and I
think that's that's what the main
takeaway um that even in very simplified
positions there are so many resources
um but the thing is you have to
concentrate you have to calculate right
right once you start relaxing that's
when your your opponent pounces um
either by making making a draw they
shouldn't have or winning a game that
should have should have drawn um so I
think there there's um there's a lot
to um to learn there and
uh I think uh it's also very useful for
people to remember that endings are
they're very diverse there's a lot of
calculation um there's uh a lot
of
um there's a lot of positional
understanding um and there's a lot of
theoretical knowledge you need as well
so it's it's it's really um it's diverse
skill set you need to to play endings
well thank you Magnus I'd like to turn
it over to Peter who doubtlessly has
questions as well
Peter yeah congratulations
Magnus it it was great to see all these
nids and actually I have one question
regarding the opening not specifically
more like psychologically that you were
the one who last year introduced this
setup with against Maxim with Bishop G5
Sicilian and then playing after E6 the
move F3 which was like a tottal shock
and then you were the one who invented
all these ACS once again on the very
highest level how does it feel that now
suddenly ding is using your weapon
against you H it's very
unpleasant because I find these
positions like equally equally
fascinating and equally difficult to
play with both
colors
um so I mean that's that's that's the
thing right like I I I find them so f
but I also know that when I play them
I'm going to make a bunch of mistakes
because they're so difficult um to play
so it's it's really an ambivalent
feeling um and well fortunately for me
um my opponent is probably going to M
make mistakes as
well yeah of course it's such a complex
opening I played also myself so much
with casparo and so and exactly that's
what I mentioned during the broadcast
that when both of you started to have
very little time like two minutes each
or even less and I was telling Yer you
know I'm not liking this fing because I
know from my experience facing Gary that
whenever we reach this terrible Big Time
trouble in the night off structures then
he was outplaying me so did you get
confidence out of this that you might
have better instincts in in these
positions um yeah I was I was definitely
hoping so
and I I certainly was thinking that when
he dropped to like 2 minutes as well
that that was probably going to be that
was probably going to be great for um
great for me yeah um and it's it's
always very good to know that even
though my king I mean technically has no
um um has no hiding place like I always
have the trick of bringing one more
piece into play if I if I can if I need
by by castling later on so
um you know uh but basically it's just
extremely difficult um and against
somebody like Maxim I probably would
would have been in even more more
trouble so yaser and Tanya back to you
all right before before we let you go we
do have a question from you for you from
our chat and um it's um about Gary's
contribution to your game you have
worked with Gary kaspro in the past and
I think it was in 2009 2010 uh what do
you think has been the biggest
contribution from that session that you
had with him in your
career um I think those sessions helped
me understand the Dynamics of chance a
lot lot better um and um it's been I
mean sometimes I've been able to to use
that knowledge and sometimes not
um but um I I I would say that's that's
the main takeaway that's that's what he
could
do a lot better than me uh even back
back then and it's still like one of the
most difficult things in in chess did
you guys work more on openings or just
uh the entire aspect the whole or was it
a more Universal training uh all aspects
of the game I would say quite Universal
but obviously um the main focus is going
to be on on the
openings at some point all right thank
you for your time and your insights
Magnus and good luck for your match
tomorrow thank you thank you
Magnus and that was world champion
Magnus Carlson yet again wrapping up his
match in three games two and a half half
and uh as he mentioned in this game it
surprised him in third in the third game
C3 surprised him and it was true that
after Knight B3 ding had a real chance
and a much better position actually
according to computer evaluations a big
Miss by ding which means that Magnus
Carlson leads their semi-final bracket
with 2-1 going into day four of the
semis but we still have one more game
coming up shortly Hikaru Nakamura
leading the third set with 2-1 which
means Daniel dubov must win this game on
demand to take it into to take it into
the blitz portion of today a really
Monumental task for for Daniel because
it's also psychologically really
difficult you're you're down on two sets
you're down in the match Peter yes what
do you think what are the chances of
Daniel being able to strike and take
this Match Into The Blitz take it Peter
what's your what's your what's your
percentage
breakdown yeah my percentage is that it
doesn't look good doesn't look good at
all I mean uh it's not just that yeah he
has to win he has to win on demand to
stay alive but he just lost with the
white pieces and now he has to do it
with black on the other hand if we we
look back at the match so far in the
first day he also had to win on demand
he managed to win with the black pieces
and then yesterday with the white pieces
he didn't got any chance he even lost
that game to Hikaru and I think the the
problem is that the more you get into
this situ a also your opponent gets more
used to how to handle the situation when
my opponent is in a must-win situation
and by now Hikaru must have uh gathered
lot of lot of confidence because he
understands that he plays well he plays
probably better than Danielle and all
these things make it I think very hard
for Daniel to to to come back I simply
couldn't agree more Peter I think that
that's the problem Tanya I mean he
danels in a very difficult
situation I am predicting a Hikaru final
Hikaru going into final before getting
any tie breaks today it's not a hot take
I know a lot of us are and that's not
breaking news but uh yes very difficult
um difficult situation for Daniel dubov
how much um I think we still have a
couple of couple of minutes before the
start of the next game let's take a look
at what our friends over in Twitter had
to say
let's see if we can get some of our
tweets up and we heard from D so thank
you tasa Peter for the wonderful
coverage enjoying every second going to
be a big void in my life after this
tournament is over worry not Dear Sir
because the voy shall not last long
chess 24 has uh uh big plans for all of
us and will be bringing us more chess
action and uh if you want to see all of
this continue and you've enjoyed the
tour and you want to support the
broadcast do consider going premium and
supporting all the work that chess 24
does but like I said lots more exciting
stuff coming up after the Magnus cson
chest St so stay tuned on chess
24 all right and um Peter yes
let's let's bring you in on the ding and
Magnus match now ding is down to one and
which means that he again Magnus needs
only one match win to to advance to the
finals uh what do you what do you think
went wrong for ding today I mean
yesterday we saw him go the positional
strategic solid approach it didn't work
out today we saw positions blow up he
played the night off he played he played
aggressively it didn't work out what's
he got to
do well uh I'll take a quick stab and
then Peter you join in as well um for me
uh just this educational moment uh that
Magnus himself pointed out Magnus chided
his move Queen B7 and ding did not find
the move Knight B3 and I think at this
highest level it's about the
opportunities that you get right Peter I
mean your opportunities are so so small
just one or two twice a game and in this
case when uh he played instead C3 he
collapsed missing opportunities is what
I meant to say yeah what I feel is that
it's connect that he was not familiar
with the position so imagine ding having
such a chance in type of positions in D4
C4 Knight F3 he would have used that
chance for sure in my opinion but I mean
uh not being an E4 player and then
getting one of the sharpest possible
positions with no time on the clock uh
it it was just too much for him to
handle and such moves like KN B if you
are not familiar with all these uh
structures it's it's not an easy and not
an obvious move at all okay and sorry to
interrupt you uh Tanya I just wanted to
say that we're off for game four uh the
semi-final between hikaro Nakamura
hikaro leads two sets to nil and he has
a lead in this uh match as well Danel
has to win and Peter it's a
Rouser yeah exactly I mean it's the same
Rous that they played today already so
we'll be very interesting to see who
deviates first so far yeah I think this
is all the same and queen D2 the move
which uh you mentioned that this
mysterious move is blitzed out
again yeah B4
kn2 A5 so so far no surprises yet
actually because at that point magnus's
game had really uh got very very sharp
we missed all this middle game action in
in that game so we'll be very
interesting and Hikaru comes up with the
move C2 C4 I would say wow if I would
have not known from myself that I love
to play C4 in all these
structures wow I'll say it for both of
us then C2 C4 uh you mentioned that you
are supporting the Giza
maroi uh chess club and when I ever I
see the pawns on C4 in E4 I think of the
maroy bind what is it that draws you to
this move C2 C4 Peter well I mean uh I
think also it has a shock effect and
another thing that uh let's not forget
black has not Castell yet so it it feels
little premature from black side that he
went so quickly B5
A5 B5 B4 A5 before castling and uh in
this Le God I feel that uh punishing it
with a timely C2 C4 because the whole
point is usually in this type of
position you never get the chance of
playing C4 because black uh captures on
CC Knight takes CC and you have opened
up the files against you yourself but
here the point is that white gets access
to the B5 square and if for example you
CLE I just go Knight B5 and I almost say
that it's game over strategically game
is over I occupy this very lovely square
and also hitting D6 and before you
generate any counterplay I have complete
I have reached complete domination of
the position so that's the justification
behind C4 that you can't take it and if
you can't take it then uh I believe that
this uh C4 structure will be much more
hard to attack than than otherwise okay
you said I can't play C after C4 I can't
take it by aasan
can I take the pawn on C4 with my
queen oh oh oh
oh Queen take C4 I mean I have so many
great options yes I mean what move like
E5 I even don't want to play it's it's
also there I would much more love to
play in the spirit like
uh like okay if I go Knight D4
and I go back with my queen let's say in
this case to
C5 to C5 okay let me play Rook
C1 and uh you kick and I move Queen B6
yeah Bishop E3 and then you go back to
B7 and you say thank you very much well
I did snap off a pawn that was actually
Defending Your King a moment yeah yeah
okay so if if you are like this and you
this then I will use brutal force yes I
understand that I I was actually afraid
of your brutal force and because in this
case after E5 this Pawn I certainly
cannot touch uh because now my Bishop on
D7 is oops it's lost and if I have to
move my knight to D5 uh Peter yeah you
have to move you don't want to move but
you have to and I understand your
feelings because uh I mean
something gonna happen to you that's for
sure I'm afraid I'm afraid that is so
true I'm really really worried about
Knight F4 I I think it might just be
lights out after that move but I
wouldn't surprise me if there are other
really really strong moves and queen
takes C4 was a kind of asking for it if
you know what I mean yeah exactly I mean
uh to be honest if you play C4 and the
opponent takes Queen takes C4 then then
you think like wow I mean what is it uh
because usually a move like Queen takes
C4 you just feel that it will not work
and you even don't want to to calculate
it and all of a sudden you open and
takes and sometimes he can take and
there is no follow up right of course
before as they say please don't run at
home before playing C4 make sure that
your opponent can't can't take it
however in the game there is some very
interesting stat iCal development
because uh after
C4 Daniel played the move H6 and now the
big question is since Hikaru took on F6
which is somewhat surprising for me
because Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen
takes
D6 we we reach a position that we
already discussed in the very first day
of their match also with the two Bishops
and being Pawn I mean a pawn sacrifice
but thanks to the pair of Bishops black
has very nice compensation and to be
honest in this structure I don't feel
that my Pawn on C4 is so great right so
it it's funny I mean it really has uh
Peter been a day of endings and we've
been seeing quite a number of them today
and interestingly enough another theme
of these end games that we're seeing is
a player is upon Pawn ahead but his
opponent has the two Bishops as a
compensation and his
and the compensation has been proven
proving itself time and time again is
that the case in this position as well
Peter I think in general in mod chess
it's it's very common that people
believe in the two Bishops of course it
depends on the structure but uh if if
the structure allows your compensation
then almost everybody believes in it but
here it's very tricky first of all
Daniel did not change the Queens he
moved the queen away from C7 to A7 which
actually given the match situation makes
perfect sense because okay let's let's
keep the game uh going with with the
Queens on the other aspect is that
Hikaru had blitzed out everything all
the way till Queen takes D6 so the big
question Daniel was faced with that what
is my opponent's preparation yeah right
and uh this is uh he he probably did not
want to find out and he just moved away
with the queen indeed Queen A7 not going
into the end game will remind everybody
I think it was was it the day one that
uh that um Danel had to win on demand
game four and he did it in an end game
with the black pieces and and here again
he has to win on Demand with the black
pieces but he assured the ending with
Queen A7 not trading and
uh you know you you mentioned Peter that
uh match circumstances may have made
that move a requirement was it a good
move
however yeah I don't know it's it's such
a complex position to be honest I also
don't really believe how white is
supposed to be better in any of these
end games but the big question is does
white care if uh if he's not better
because he might just not want to be
better he feels like I'm P up I have a
very stable solid position you might
have a compensation which guarantees you
maximum quality or Draw then please do
it yeah and uh after Queen A7 now that
Hikaru load done I wonder if he's
regretting this uh approach or if he
believes that okay actually you have
compensation but maybe with move P move
because Queen A7 was not the Move That
was supposed to be played I can punish
you for that
exactly uh so Knight D4 you got ideas of
uh Knight C6 and uh Knight
B5 um I I desperately want my king on
the king side suddenly and I'm thinking
that whether I like it or not my Bishop
on F6 is good I may have to just T
tickle the queen away with the move
Bishop E7 so I can
Castle yeah exactly so Bishop E7 and now
if I want to force an end game I can
force an end game with Knight C6 right
ah that is true true you're absolutely
right I have to but but on the other
hand we get this very very funny
position that after 97 let's say Bishop
C5 Knight B5 the Knight is lovely on B5
but it's also almost trapped yeah it's
not going anywhere exactly and after
King E7 again I think it's that same end
game that uh of complexity uh White has
extra Pawn I don't think it's that
meaningful I think that black has a a
comfortable game actually EX exactly I
mean all this G5 Bishop C6 and then just
try to play for some G5 G4 break with
the Knight on B5 and also the bishop on
F1 to be honest in the other position
when I just Without Really calculating
just intuitively I thought that one of
White's idea in this setup after taking
on D6 is maybe to bring the Rook back
and get the Knight via C1 to D3 and on
DC the Knight would do very nice job
covering all the dark squares that was
one of my my intuition how I thought
maybe Hikaru wanted to play The
Possession but I anyway didn't
understand what what he wants from it
right well an intuitive uh moment there
with the night Sian an educational
moment I just want to give another big
shout out to Julius bar for their
support Julius bar is a private bank in
Switzerland and they have aligned
themselves with a Magnus Carlson tour
for as a sponsor sometimes I remember
when I was a kid I don't know if you had
this in Hungary uh we when we were kids
we we had the march of dyes and what we
did is we went to our neighbors and we
said would you sponsor me to make take a
walk and we would walk a mile and we
would make dimes and then donate the
dimes to the March of Dimes uh charity
foundation in this case Julia's bar is
aligning itself with Magnus for each
victory of a set uh they are donating a
thousand dollars towards our Kea goal of
$50,000 so uh essentially yesterday's
Victory by Magnus and today's Victory by
Magnus has cost Julius Barett I'm sure
they're grateful for the opportunity to
uh support Kaa nonetheless uh so uh as
Magna said his so his he's aligned
himself with Kaa as he's also going to
donate 10% of his prize winnings of this
finals uh to Kaa so you can join uh with
Magnus with Peter Leo and basil ivanchuk
and other great stars um and uh well you
can do that in a multitude of ways you
can donate you can become a subscriber
sponsor to ke directly and you could
also uh buy a chess 24 premium 50% of
which is going to go to Kaa so I very
happy to get that in um what's happening
now Peter uh we've kind of going back
and forth a little in this game yeah but
I think we have some very important
development strategically okay because I
like the way how Hikaru reacted I mean
this that we discussed with Knight D4
and going for that end game I I felt
like it's the wrong approach just I had
to illustrate that option because it was
very straightforward the move E4 E5
fighting for the dark squares is much
more in the spirit and also much more in
Hikaru style so after Bishop E7 which
was forced Queen D4 was played now again
this is like some kind of a mind game
yeah that Hikaru probably expects Daniel
not to change the Queens anyway because
he insisted of on keeping the Queens on
the board
so Queen C7 had been played and white
played the move Queen F4 and why I like
this Pawn on E5 because
certainly uh suddenly completely new
aspects appeared I mean white has this
option of rerooting the Knight via G3 to
E4 also from GC to H5 get the bishop to
D3 and generate dangerous attack against
the black king if it stays in the center
or if it castels short and if black for
example shows too much respect for this
plan then he might have to make some
concession which otherwise he would not
like to do exactly and and Peter as you
were just mentioning these uh how can
else can I say but very tempting options
bringing the Knight to E4 that's just
like a a beautiful Outpost for White's
Knight and it's ready to jump uh to D6
to begin with and even possibly the F6
if uh Black's King is is kingside
castled um yeah put the Knight on e4 and
sign me up for White's position Peter
yeah I mean one of the resources black
has in this position is that whenever
you go Knight G3 okay I'm not I will
just make a pass yeah just to illustrate
what I'm talking about white goes Knight
G6 just one move away from playing
Knight E4 but black has this lovely
little touch F7 F5 changing the
structure of the position killing the
Knight on G3 stopping Knight E4 and
making good use that you can't take
aasan because your queen is hanging
whoops so it's not all roses uh Knight
G3 Knight E4 doesn't come automatically
because the queen is unfortunately as
you just nicely showed uh not defend it
yeah and Daniel basically even said okay
if I have this idea then let me just
castle and Hikaru played Knight D4 so
now the Knight is going the other way
yeah going the other way yeah because
the point is that probably black can
anyway never allow afford to to let this
white knight land on D6 but if after
Knight B5 you will be forced to trade
Bishop takes B5 then we get this
opposite colored Bishop stuff when white
king feels quite safe and let's not
forget that white
has this idea Bishop D3 Queen E4 aiming
for Queen H7 Checkmate and it's uh it
looks like a very primitive attack but
it's not easy to to defend because
whenever black plays some G6 then white
is ready to break this with H5 yeah I
remember from the new and chess magazine
this beautiful interview with Boris basy
where Boris uh talks about his youth at
a Pioneer Palace and there was a with
there was a
player at uh the club the Pioneer Palace
who he loved to get the battery of the
queen battery Bishop to D3 Queen to
E4 and uh that was what he played for
and he was always crushed when his
opponent had a defense like F7
F5 that he couldn't have it he couldn't
play anymore the battery was was uh was
blocked and he collapsed and uh Boris
remembered that uh story with with great
fondness uh we do have A4 on the board
and queen E4 uh Peter yeah and I'm
shaking my head because I just don't
like this A4 at all I mean allowing
White playing Queen E4 the main idea
with getting Bishop D3 getting out of
this pin I I felt like it's decisive for
this position that can black timely play
some F6 or play some F5
but if you let white get the stab
stabilizer Queen E4 then this can I mean
the question is only how bad it is but
it's never going to be good exactly so
A4 Queen E4 and now F5 on the board an
indication that something has gone
seriously wrong uh by Danel to
allow this well I mean I want to say
very uh brutal battery uh Queen H7 and
the black king is just going to blow be
blown into the center whether he likes
it or
not yeah I mean it it looks awful for
black and uh I mean there is also no
real counterplay I mean white is so
dominant in the center thanks to this
queen queen H7 idea black has damaged
Pawn structure the king is weak um I
don't know I I think that that's it I
mean against Hikaru there is no way back
from here
you're just giving a whole bullet list
of reasons of things having gone wrong
and I I completely agree I mean
domination in the center first of all
thank you very much for the extra Pawn
suddenly the pawn on C2 the pawn on C4
pardon me and not on C2 is great right
because now there's no A3 Queen C3 ideas
so just a whole Christmas wish list of
happiness for white
yeah well I mean uh I told you from the
beginning that I love this phone on seaf
in these structures now I'm happy that
finally I also seem to to respect this
and you like it as well just as me uh
the only thing I I'm little concerned
about not to be not that white suddenly
relaxes because let's not forget that
black still has this incredible powerful
duck where Bishop on F6 this is the soul
of his uh position I mean believe me any
chess player would love to trade one of
his looks now for this bishop let's just
remove it and continue the game and all
of a sudden black would be completely
lost exactly but thanks to this bishop
there is still hidden resource and
already the fact that despite White
having this queen H7 check and bringing
not that much it already shows that yeah
Black's position still has
resources right and um now now having
said all of that and the fact that you
pointed out the bishop on F6 is kind of
the glue in the position that's keeping
Black's position float G4 G5 uh is a
very obvious and tempting attacking uh
move for whites Peter what do you think
about that yeah I was I was expecting
that you're gonna do this to me I'm
gonna put
you you never get a chance to attack me
I'll ask the tough
questions well I mean as you said I mean
white has all of these advantages that
Dan has allowed white to acrew to White
and it's not therefore uh a coincidence
that G4 looks very powerful to my eyes I
mean Hikaru had played so quickly once
again I think he had 17 minutes on the
clock by the time we started to discuss
uh the position Peter and G4 is played
so I'm very glad that I'm not the only
one confronted with this question what
to do after G4 thank you very
much this is where you get the moment to
say just a second I think Dan's gonna
have to answer this question of yours
yaser and he's done it actually he done
it very quickly too I mean uh in a tough
position he saw Queen C5 and he's maybe
on a good day looking at an opportunity
after say Knight B5 to go Queen F2 and
do a little kicking himself Peter yeah
absolutely I mean while we were
discussing I also felt like I have the
option between Queen E5 which doesn't
really look like an option and queen C5
and the more I looked at Queen C5 the
more annoying it looked like because
it's not so easy to to defend this
Knight on D4 and if you move the Bishop
from DC to C2 then I might hit you with
BC and we finally get the cont to play
what we are dreaming of with the black
pieces yeah indeed but now having said
that like you said the the Knight on D4
is suddenly under attack um I got to do
something Peter yeah you got to do
something but before you were enjoying
so much
the it's your task not to deal with this
okay I'll fall okay I I'll go Bishop C2
then I mean since uh I feel some kind of
obligation to to explain I mean did you
say Bishop E2 or or C2 sorry ah no
because hiu played Bishop E2 and I know
that everybody follows your suggestions
ah okay in this case I I'm quite sure
that Hikaru thought that B4
B3 uh would hit would as you said you
you're trying as black to get in your
counter play and B3 so he car play the
move Bishop E2 to avoid opening lines on
the queen side yes exactly I mean now of
course he gave up all these ideas with
queen H7 but I mean those Queen H7
checks didn't really go anywhere anyway
so he's more about stabilizing but if
Bishop E2 was force then I'm not sure if
all this G I mean G4 and Bishop E2 fits
together so well and Danielle uses the
time and goes Rook ad8 putting more
pressure on the D4 Knight I somehow I
have the feeling that the game is
getting really sharp and double-edged
okay but here it comes uh G5 Peter yeah
G5
played I mean uh in some ways you're
hitting the Knight on D4 I get it
seriously I really do but I think as
white a lot of white players are kind of
relieved when The Rook left the a file
it's like okay now you're not going to
come after my king that that that's good
news for me and he's taken twice on G5
here yeah he took and actually Queen H7
is back in business uh of course this as
people say or we used to learn in the in
the chess clubs in Hungary that the the
threat is stronger than the execution
yeah so it's much better not to give
this check but to to keep it in your
pocket and disturb your opponent that he
has to calculate every time that what
will be the final outcome of any of this
any of these checks and white has a very
nice choice now with okay Rook D G1
probably going to be met by Queen E5
black has to Black has to control the
dark squares and in this respect F4 is
the move that comes to mind and yeah
Hikaru played F4 yeah I think it's going
to be very hard not to play the move F4
after all if the queen goes to C5 or
somewhere along the fifth rank like the
C5 Square you you are set up for Rook
H5 and queen G6 and again it's like kind
of funny that uh I've set up all of
these checkmating patterns in this this
chessable winning winning
uh winning combinations course and it's
funny that we're now seeing that you
know Rook H5 Queen G6 Rook H1 Rook h8 is
mate so after F4 we see the move Queen
G3 probably not a a happy move for uh
duboff yeah not at all I mean it feels
completely lost I mean black seems to be
lost without any chance I mean is Rook
G1 to G2 just oh I'm sorry D4 is hanging
it's getting
late oops I apologize Rook G2 Queen
takes D4 is not not the way I intended
the game to continue sorry yeah and
Hikaru went for Rook D3 I mean the the
simple point is that when you see such a
queen on GC you you want to trap this
queen yeah I mean exactly you you feel
like you forget about Checkmate you
don't want to give Checkmate anymore you
want to you want to clap this queen and
say to your opponent that you know I
mean you should never do this again in
your life because this is not the way to
not the way to play chess yeah but look
at this might just force the repetition
because it it wins for him the match
exactly I think you spotted the same per
uh per Perpetual Pursuit uh uh as I did
you just keep hitting the queen with the
with the Rook on F1 to H1 and back and
forth and as you just so uh pointed out
a draw is all Hikaru needs and it's
already drawn finish finish bito bandito
well I I must say uh a big hearty
congratulations to my Countryman Hikaru
Nakamura is he wins all three matches
really going into this match I thought
it was going to be a very competitive
match it wouldn't have surprised me if
it went to five sets I did predict taru
that I didn't
see him in this kind of beast mode uh I
think it was day one that game one of
one was Dan's uh moment and he never he
never uh got into this match Peter
absolutely I mean uh very finally a very
smooth victory for for Hikaru but I mean
those matches are always very very
tensed and very tricky because the final
result final score never really shows
how big comp I mean how big fight it was
and I'm pretty sure now we will have the
chance of asking Karu the question how
he felt it was it was a tense fight it
was a really tense fight absolutely uh
Tanya you're here with
iaru yes yes we are joined by our first
finalist Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru
congratulations on the win as well as
booking your spot in the finals thank
you yeah it was a pretty pretty
interesting match today and I was just a
little bit fortunate to come out on
top that's interesting that you say that
because to us it felt like you were in
control uh pretty much throughout the
day take us through the critical moments
in the games let's start with the with
game
one yeah I mean I didn't think game one
was particularly um exciting for the
most part I mean I thought the position
was just very dry um maybe I was
marginally worse in this end game
somewhere but I didn't think game one
was very very interesting it just denil
had to exchange pieces and once we reach
this end game just a queen Rook bishop
and five against Queen Rook bishopman
five I mean I I maybe white is optically
better but I never really thought it was
was very very dangerous so I mean this
this game wasn't wasn't all that
interesting for either of us but game
two of course I probably was winning at
some point and um and then I misplayed
this it's just one of these yeah I mean
somewhere somewhere in this middle game
denil went quite wrong I mean he kept
playing he switched back to his Rouser
and um yeah like G4 H5 I take yeah I
mean this yeah somewhere somewhere after
after B3 I thought this was very good I
don't know maybe B3 was was like too
optimistic to go Bishop C4 or maybe I
should have just gone F4 F5 um but I I
got a very good position and somehow I
just didn't didn't find the The Knockout
blow in this uh late middle game early
end
game right and then and then it felt
like Daniel managed to managed to hold
it together in this one and then game
three um it finally you struck and what
where do you think it went all wrong for
white in this game yeah I mean this game
much like the match it hinged on sort of
one of danil's white games where he
probably was a little bit better um and
he couldn't find the right continuation
I thought somewhere in this middle game
if you go ahead to around the point that
he played uh yeah I just keep going I
want to say somewhere around the point
that yeah right right around here after
Queen C4 Queen E5 I I had a feeling that
white should be much better but trying
to prove it of course is very difficult
um in a rapid game I was I was very
happy with the way I defended this
because already here I was down the
clock I thought I was in in in real
trouble um I was just very pleased with
the moves I came up with because I
optically when you look at on first
glance I think it's quite quite
dangerous um like yeah I played Rook E A
I completely missed um I I should have
gone H6 because I completely missed he
could go Queen C4 and F4 here I only saw
Queen B5 um and F4 and then after F4
like I'm I'm very lucky here that
somehow it's not it's not just lost
after um after Queen
E6 yeah B5 was was a big mistake by
denal to be fair because I think here
when whites up the pawn it's probably
still very clear but I think white has
to be better with the extra Pawn danil
missed this B5 Rook B3 trick um where
basically after Rook C6 Queen F7 the
pawn on B5 can't be protected because
when you go Queen C4 there's Rook B4 and
he used a lot of time and this is really
where where it all went wrong because he
played Knight C3 and then I mean maybe
it's still holdable but I I thought that
um Knight B4 was was also very good with
Knight D3 and just um the rest I think
was very very messy uh denil defended
quite well but then he slipped like he
played this Rook C move we just keep
going way ahead um yeah he play he
played like at this point I got lower on
time than him and I I yeah
G4 and I got lower on time than him and
I was just going to make the draw here
after Rook G8 Rook d8 because I I only
had like 30 seconds but then denil got
too creative I think he just forgot when
he went Rook C8 he forgot that I could
just take and go go Knight D7 and after
Rook d8 um just King E7 and and I I I
don't know if he saw this or he just
missed the whole thing but after after
Rook D7 King D7 the king is in if you go
back go
back yeah just go back to after King
E7 was if he forgot that on Rook D7 King
D7 um if Knight Knight E5 King D6 takes
and F6 I'm I'm in the box like on F6 I
take uh H4 King D7 H5 King E7 doesn't
really matter and the king gets back to
the back to stop the pawn so I'm not
sure if he missed this or what happened
but once he went Rook C8 and I was able
to trade on G 4 and go kn7 um I don't
think the result was in doubt and um and
I I thought from here I I played played
pretty smoothly to uh to
convert and then in fact in game four at
the very end uh you are you're the one
who's pressing and in fact very close to
winning a very professional approach by
just finding a repetition and finishing
the match there yeah I mean I didn't
really know what was going on here but
but the thing is the problem with the
whole whole game is that when I went
Queen E4 um like on move 20 I thought
that already was just over I thought
Bishop D3 next move and I must have a
Checkmate but after F5 takes Bishop F6
it's not as clear as it looks and in
retrospect I think I should have just
gone G4 here um just to go G4 G5
immediately rather than wasting a Tempo
because after Bishop
D3 um in the game somehow I couldn't
find the Checkmate here like I I really
wanted to go yeah go back inside G4 I
really wanted to go Queen H7 King f8
Bishop
G6 and and the point is that let's just
say black plays like Queen takes C4 for
example
I have the very nice move Knight to F5
here and now I'm threatening the
Checkmate on h8 um and it if takes on F5
then I go Rook D7 and just the whole
house collapses right um so this is kind
of what I was hoping for but then at the
board after um after thinking forever
there I saw this move B3 and and for
some reason I I just I couldn't find the
continuation I'm sure the computer says
Knight F5 is still winning but like
Knight F5 and and I don't know B takes
A2 King A1 Bishop B2 and I I mean I
suspect it's just winning after King B2
Rook B8 uh King B2 Queen E5 or something
no sorry Rook B8 not Queen E5 Rook
B8 and I mean maybe here it's winning
with King A1 but but again it's like I
mean you feel like you've done something
wrong and if if you miscalculate here
you're just going to get checkmated as
well which which really doesn't help
matter so um I suspect there was some
line in here like this that was winning
but I I couldn't figure it out and I
just thought I mean I I thought it would
be more practical uh but I I blender
Queen C5 and so I was a little bit lucky
um that I still had enough play because
I only looked at Queen B6 I forgot that
he Queen C5 with with the idea that um
like here if I go Bishop uh not Bishop
B2 sorry if I go like Queen
H7 King f8 Knight E2 here then he is
Queen E5 whereas with the queen on B6
there's no there's no way to create the
battery with the Checkmate so um I I
kind of overlooked this but luckily it
it didn't matter and then then you know
at at the end as we go go forward kind
of I just play play all the natural
moves and and I mean maybe there's some
way to win but why why bother like
there's there's just no need at this
point um so wh why why why why do that
when when a draw is good enough yeah
absolutely and then you just uh you
you're the first finalist uh even you
could not have expected this semi-final
to go as smooth as it
did yeah I mean I I think a lot of what
happened in semi-final hinge on the
first day but since the matches over I
will say say a couple of other things
which is I very strongly felt that in in
the match we played in the final of um I
think it was Lind Doris Abby event that
I sort of beat myself I felt that there
were many positions where I was a little
bit better in pressing and then when the
advantage slipped away from me I would
keep trying to win and in turn I would
turn it into a loss so I felt in many
ways um the that was the reason that the
match got away from me in the final I
felt like in this match it was quite the
opposite where uh when denil had a
slight advantages he did the same thing
he would take the slight advantages and
when it was gone he would try still to
keep the game going instead of making
the draw and and so throughout this
match my main approach was just be solid
and don't beat myself basically if the
advantage isn't there you know just play
solid make the draws he has he's gonna
have to beat me at some point and so um
you know when I had that thought process
throughout this match I think I think it
served me very well because that in the
previous match I did very I did very
much feel that when I got the advantages
and I let them slip I turn the draw the
wins in the winning positions are much
better into not only draws but then into
losses and in a match format that's
that's pretty uh pretty
deadly that's actually quite fascinating
because uh I was thinking that um you
know throughout the tour both of you
have played you played in the linduras
Abby final as well as then in in
chessable Masters you beat dubov so you
sort of traded blows throughout the tour
and then this big one here you uh won it
in dominating style and you mentioned
that you figured what went wrong with
you in the earlier matches that you had
with Daniel did you also pick up up
something about perhaps Daniel's style
of play or a weakness in his in his
handling that you might have used in
this final yeah I mean so so first of
all when we talk about the the previous
match the reason that I lost that match
is because I lost games with white um in
the second mini match I lost the first
game in the alen Sicilian and then in
the third and final match I lost the
second game in a uh I think it was a um
it was an accelerated Dragon so I lost
two games with white in the second and
third matches which are very critical in
terms of me not winning that match and
then in O overall as far as this match
goes one thing that I noticed uh
especially yesterday and I really picked
up on it is that denil really likes to
play uh he likes to play sort of dynamic
positions that are creative and so
starting with this first shes cop game
yesterday I decided to try and make it
as boring as possible and try to make
the positions as dry where it's very
technical and you kind of just have to
play play normal looking moves but
there's very little room for creativity
so that was one thing that I I very much
strived for um was to play things that
were very solid and very dry where you
can't be super
creative that's uh that's really
interesting to hear the concept of um
playing against uh the player and uh
coming to this match the semi- final
that we
had it also felt like you mentioned it
yourself on day one um game two really
set the tone and things could have been
very different like if we had to point
out one moment when things drastically
changed and we would talking to Magnus
about this as well was that game to when
you were on the back foot and then
Daniel blundered with King E7 you
immediately uh found this queen G7 Rook
D6 idea and since then Daniel just never
found his rhythm in the match if you had
to point a turning if you had to point
out a turning point would that be it in
the match yeah I think I think the fact
that I was able to steal that first
first match which I should have lost by
I mean any any normal like any normal
standard I should have lost that that
first match especially esally after the
way the first game went I think when I
stole that second game um or not stole
second game but I mean kind of when he
blundered and I won that second game
that really turned the tide and I I very
very much felt that once I won that
match when I was not playing very good
chess I mean that first game was just
like I could have resigned on move 10 or
whatever it was um uh yeah I felt that
when I won that I I felt felt much
better yesterday and it was it was still
quite tense but the other thing I would
say is that because I had the previous
match in the final I I also felt that I
took my foot off the gas like when I was
up one I won the first mini match the
first game of the second day I played
this Alin Sicilian and denil played a
great end game very technical and won
that game and so I felt that I took my
foot off the gas as well um and so I was
very mindful of that and I was just uh
really really just focused on trying to
play play good chess and uh and and I
felt that yesterday today um I was just
I was a little bit more precise and I
found some of the better moves in the in
the critical moments more so then
denil hear you've also been I would say
the most consistent player throughout
the T this is your third final in uh the
Magnus Carlson chest T you haven't
played one events out of four events
that you've played this is your uh this
is your third final and if you had to
point out that one overreaching skill
and you can't say time management
because we all know that you're a beast
at that an over theboard scale or or an
approach that you have that has sort of
worked worked for you and responsible
for your successful play in this very
very difficult format what would that be
yeah I think in general it's just I tend
to be very solid uh I play a much
different style than I used to when I
was younger but for the most part I've
I've I've felt that if I don't lose
games the opportunities will come to me
so in in general terms when when when I
don't lose games I figure sooner or
later I'll be more accurate or more
precise in my opponents I'll get
opportunities and I would say against
with the exception of maybe one player
that that tends to work very well the
problem is there's one player who is
capable of not losing even more so than
me and being slightly more precise so
that that is a slight issue um that that
I have to face but but but overall I
feel that I tend to be more accurate and
um if I don't lose games I'll get the
opportunities and and it seems to have
worked out in this tour and do you also
feel that throughout the progress of the
tour you have also seen a progress in
your own style and approach and sort of
coming into this format do you think
that your own game has progressed in
this format playing so many events and
that's something that worked in your
favor over Daniels well I mean honestly
I feel like uh I was just playing myself
into form in this match where I did I
did not do any preparation ahead of this
match to be quite honest and um looked
at a little bit of stuff but I feel like
for me since it's been a while I just
I've just been playing myself into into
form and you mentioned that there's this
one player against whom there is a
little difficulty with that approach uh
are you you've got two two days now
before uh before the finals are you
already assuming that you're going to be
up against Magnus or going to wait for
the final result or will prep begin soon
yeah you know I I mean to get back to
that point I was making earlier and this
I think is is again a sty stylistic
thing is is what I was saying is that I
feel for the most part I'm more accurate
than most players I defend extremely
well um and and and the reason that I
have the issues with Magnus or at least
I've had the issues in these online
events very specifically is because
Magnus is slightly better at defending
slightly better at pressing end game so
he this very slight margin when you're
playing against someone who slightly Who
does these things I mean I wouldn't even
say there's a big difference but he does
all these little things slightly better
that's when you kind of have to start
mixing up with the style and playing
differently so I'll be doing I'll be
doing some some research and and
checking out but I'm going to assume
Magnus will win because until he loses
uh I mean until I see it until I see it
I'm not going to believe it so let's put
it that way fair enough and from your
perspective so far in the tour you've
been a part of four four events um which
one would you say has been your
highlight in terms of uh performance uh
looking back at the tour so far yeah I I
would say overall the win I mean even
though I lost in the final to denil uh
the the lind Doris Abby tournament for
sure is my favorite because I did beat
Magnus in in our in our mini match so up
to this point that's been my favorite
event uh but just in general I've just
been very happy that in a lot of
critical moments um I've sort of come up
clutch I've won some games when I've
needed to like if I don't win this game
against lvon I think this this fourth
game of the first match in Lind Doris
there's a very good chance I would not
have made this final because if I had
been down one one zero um who knows how
that goes I I might might not even make
the final so I think the fact that that
I've come up with some critical
victories and I've played very well in
in the moments that matter the most has
been the thing I'm most happy about I
could agree more with that and coming in
today Hikaru did you also feel that
you're up to sets uh confident of course
but also that you have been the better
player and the more informed player and
you you deserve to be be in this final
was that um something that you felt that
that is your um that you deserve to be
in the final yeah I you know it's weird
today was probably the most calm I felt
out of all three days I felt very tense
the first day and the second day today
was the most calm I felt because again I
really felt like yesterday there was
sort of a breakthrough I truly
understood kind of the way that denil
likes to play in a way that I don't
think I had completely understood before
so once I sort of understood the sort of
games positions that he likes and and
knowing what I really wanted to avoid
that made me a more confident even
though I was up two nothing as I said
because I had that that match in the
final where I I felt that I took my foot
off the gas I'm like okay I'm up one
nothing I mean surely I can't lose the
next two days and and of course Neil
played played great chess and and I lost
that final so the main thing was just
try try to be calm but most importantly
remember that it's not over until it's
over and just really try to put pressure
on him uh today hey G from the audience
point of view I can I can tell you that
you know you just made this semi-final
look so easy and it was something that I
think uh you were the favorite going
into the match but I it would be hard to
say that any anybody expected for it to
be such a dominant show from your end
you've shown consistent play throughout
the tour a very very deserving spot in
the finals we can't wait regardless of
who you're playing against it's going to
be an epic fight thank you so much and
I'm going to hand it over to Yas and
Peta to quiz you uh with further
questions well I don't know if I can
quiz you uh any further uh hikara just
hearty congratulations earlier during
the broadcast Tanya had read a Twitter
and that and the writer had said uh that
you're a great attacker and you've
changed your style and I was quick to
point out that you've become a very very
good endgame player and I I cited an
interview that you had with Jennifer
shahadi where you yourself said yes you
had concentrated and you're proud of
your game play It's kind of showed
itself in this
match yeah I mean I I think that's true
like like I was saying before um one
thing that I've that I've learned how to
do is sort of play certain very slow
kind of end games and um and outplay my
opponents which is great I mean it's
very good to play like that as I said
before there's only one problem there's
someone who does that better than me so
uh it's worked against most people
obviously um and and i' I've worked
really hard on it um and and and I think
it shows in a lot these rapid games
where players get low on time and and um
that's why I've been so successful I
think in this event is that I get into a
lot of these sort of slow middle game
slow end games drier type of positions
and I'm very good at converting which
works against everyone except for one
guy
unfortunately right well again
congratulations I'll turn it over to
Peter yeah congratulations Hikaru I only
have one little question about the
opening because yeah it was such an
opening debate and I believe that we
will not be seeing the in the final so
apologize please forgive me to ask you
but probably you are not revealing any
big secret that what was your
preparation for this game because when
you played C4 I was telling y said that
I like this approach very much this is
very much from my heart and then all of
a sudden after H6 I see you trade your
dark sped Bishop atempo so it must have
been your preparation what what what was
it well I mean C4 is preparation but I
didn't actually look at H6 so I just
played Bishop F6 right away CU it looked
like a logical move um I suspect Bishop
E3 is actually the correct move the more
I think about it but uh yeah Chris
Little John my second he he mentions C4
to me against a specific move order that
denil had played in the second game and
if you can kind of close down the whole
Queen side then it makes for a very easy
and very smooth game so I thought I
thought in general everything worked out
I thought denil was maybe if there's one
thing I would critique him on is that he
was too set in his opening approach um
he he he only played the the the Rouser
and he only played the shabashov and I
think that might have I mean he's such a
creative player that I thought maybe he
should have mixed it up a little bit
more than
that yeah good and just one question
because we were debating with Yas said
that what would have been your setup in
in this position after King E7 in the
end game after king7 in the end game
yeah I think I was just GNA go um I was
gonna go Rook
D3 I think I think I was going to go
Rook D3 and Knight C uh yeah Rook D3 and
Knight C1 was my
idea yeah I mean black is completely
fine yeah exactly that's why we got
confused that you blitzed out everything
and we were not entirely sure that this
is so convincing the this end game yeah
well I don't think it's great for white
um but I I think I mean I don't know why
black should be better I put yeah
exactly I mean we felt that maybe it's
just your strategy that okay you don't
want Advantage though is good and okay
please show me what you got but it was
kind of little bit intriguing and after
Daniel moved Queen A7 we felt like oh oh
this is maybe not going to work very
well for Daniel because then you get
your type of positions and when you once
you got this E5 Queen F4 in we felt like
we are not happy we would not be we
would not be happy to be in Daniel shoes
anymore yeah but I mean okay like you
can say the same thing about many
situations it's like um was it Yan in
the final against Magnus the last event
he was in the fourth game he was in a
mus situation and um and Yan played This
Modern defense and Magnus just trade off
the Queens because he only needed a draw
when he totally could have gotten an
advantage so it's it's kind of there's
that balance between what what you're
looking for in the game and I think when
you only need a draw it's on your
opponent to prove it which is why denil
did not trade the Queens he went Queen
A7 because it's a must-win game like if
he trades queens and we draw the end
game I mean he's he still is out out so
I I actually when he started thinking I
knew he would go Queen A7 yeah that's
exactly what we saw with yasa that it
was a very interesting psychological
approach from your
side yeah I mean again I think that's
that's the the thing is in a must-win
game when you're the black piece is
always just it's very unpleasant because
you have to do something that's dubious
um at the very least to try and create
some kind of imbalance so uh that's what
uh that that's what that that's what
denil tried to do and I think it was a
spot where he should he normally he
would just trade Queens the game would
have been a draw but since a draw wasn't
enough for him I I thought the decision
was was 100% correct to play Queen
A7 all right thank you iar back to
Y uh nothing again he Caro thank you so
much for joining us and sharing your
time and and building questions from our
viewers Tanya do we have any more
questions from the viewers that you
might want to ask Hikaru as you get to
enjoy some free days hiar thank you so
much aaru once again and a big
congratulations on booking your spot in
the finals and we cannot wait to see you
in action I think this is a dream final
setup either ways whether you play ding
or Magnus thank
you see you
guys all right so our first finalist of
the Magnus Carlson chest store 2020 is
Hikaru Nakamura what and in what style
absolutely dominating his semi-final
bracket against Daniel dubov in three
matches finishing it up wrapping it up
in style and not just the scoreboard but
the level of play I think yaspo we can
all agree that hiar Nakamura is the
deserving finalist no question
impressive play Tanya definitely and
Peter and I I can tell you the may maybe
the match score um is boastful for
Hikaru but you know when you look at
those games uh small chances for Dan yes
but hikara was the overall deserved
winner yeah absolutely I mean I also
fully agree and what we also discussed
that's why I asked Hikaru this question
that since he he faced three times this
uh task of that his opponent has to try
to win at all cost it was very
interesting to see how he approached
this last game and he was very practical
he understood that Daniel will never
change queens and will Sid step and by
Sid stepping he gives hiar more chances
and it it was very very
instructive and of course the social
media world is going wild with GGO for
Hikaru um yes P do you know what that is
no no please
inform so it's um I I don't think I'm
very I'm very good at it but I have some
idea I'll try and explain it to you and
maybe chat will then correct me if I I'm
wrong so you know how Yas Peta in the
earlier days when you when you played a
really nice game and you showed whose
boss people would tip their hat or bow
down to you or just um you know a little
Applause nowadays all of that's gone
it's goodbye to all those fruties and
it's all about G which is good game yo
good game I likeed it uh it's I like
snooker and they have the World
Championship in snooker when your
opponent in snooker makes a really good
shot on the table you tap the table to
with your stick to show respect like you
know good
safety GG this is this is the equal of
showing respect nowadays yes and that's
just how it's done and Hikaru Nakamura
showing us how it's done you know what
Peter I can't wait for the finals and I
think ding of course has a big task cut
up for him he's Magnus Carlson needing
one set win to qualify for the finals
dingler and has to bounce back first to
level scores and it's not easy ding to
win the finals to to qualify for the
finals needs to win the remaining two
sets against the world champion that's
not going to be easy for him but I think
uh tomorrow's match is absolutely
critical and it could mean that we
either have our second finalist tomorrow
or we're in for a day five of the
semi-finals in any case I cannot wait
for it let's get our final thoughts from
our experts Peter your final thoughts on
how today went well in general I would
say that uh what strikes me is that you
remember we talked before the final
started that who are the favorites and I
told you that yeah I understand that
probably Hikaru is little bit slightly
favorite thanks to his uh experience and
Magnus of course is Magnus but uh what I
feel during this this F that once the
favorites settled in and felt more and
more confident with each game that's
when their superiority was uh growing
and uh in this respect uh that's exactly
the reason why I feel that Ding has now
very difficult task that Magnus fully
settled into this match he regained his
confidence and in order to to strike
back somehow ding has to disbalance
Magnus right from the beginning tomorrow
and it's easier say done because how do
you disbalance Magnus I don't know what
I could suggest for for ding but he has
to do it somehow if he wants to be in
the
final he definitely needs to needs to
change something yes your thoughts yeah
I agreed and yet having said all of that
I would think of the very very few
players in the world that give ma in
this trouble ding Lin is one of them and
ding has got the game that he could
force uh a game five
uh but Magnus man he just picked up two
days of confidence and today especially
winning two and a half half yeah it
feels like Magnus is in in the driver's
seat to wrap things up tomorrow but on
the again I have to say ding Lin has a
game that can
win and also let's not forget that
Magnus has wrapped up both his games in
Just Three G both the matches in just
three games uh which just shows that
when he's um he's on his aame is just so
hard and that's I think it was really
interesting to get hikaru's insights as
well onto it Hikaru has been the only
player throughout the tour who's knocked
out Magnus uh in a semi-final it
happened in the Linder asabi Sensational
matchup that was and and what an what an
epic battle it was and Hikaru Nakamura
beat Magnus Carlson in that um and I
think it was really interesting to hear
him say that how Magnus that even the
the strength difference is not that much
but it just feels like Magnus does every
small thing just a little better than
these other guys what did you think
about that take on Magnus by
Hikaru uh Peter you're take first crack
on that one because I I I sure had a
perspective yeah exactly I mean as a
player I would say that this is one of
the most unpleasant task because when
you feel like your opponent is clearly
Superior to you in some aspect of the
game but you know that you have your own
trumps in your hands then uh you feel
like yeah you have all the chances I
mean you just have to try to get those
type of positions where you you feel
that you might be superior but when you
feel like everywhere where you are very
good at and your opponent is just a
little little tiny bit better it's a
very frustrating uh moment and uh I'm
very curious to see how hiar with handle
this situation he has two days time to
figure out his strategy and this already
he mentioned that yeah he will try to uh
make good use of this two days and
that's that's what he has to he has to
find because if you go into the match
that you believe that my o your opponent
is little bit better everywhere then you
will not get a chance and I'm pretty
sure that if hear also reveal these
things then he already has something in
his mind how he could turn the
tables interesting uh uh just a
quickly my perspective um it's funny
today we talk about Magnus Carlson the
number one ranked player in the world
right and that maybe for well more or
less let's say the last 10 years he's
been number one or at that level and
sometimes there's been a gap between him
and say fabbi or dingler in or even
hikaro for that matter Shack Mami daro
became number two in the world I believe
uh leavon Ron and but the bottom line is
the number one rated player in the world
has been Magnus and the comparisons that
hearo was making was that well there's
just these small little little little
variations small differences and it's
funny it might sound boastful but in
truth that's the way I see it as well
one of the things is Hikaru had this
incredibly negative score in classical
chess correct me if I'm wrong but I
think it was 10 to
nothing right I mean it was just like it
was terrible it was just really really
really terrible and if it was in fact 10
to nothing that was 50 rating points
that hearu was gifting to Magnus and
that 50 rating points was what was
making Magnus number one in the world if
it CaRu had some score let's say six to4
something that some kind of a score that
was more suggestive of their ratings
Magnus would never have been you know
this absolute absolute number one in the
world so uh now again I still don't know
what the current score is I do believe
that that that hikaro finally got a a
classical Victory but isn't that
remarkable to think that just those
small small differences that they C they
added up to a tell tended nothing score
in classical chess but not in Rapid and
Blitz
indeed yes I just want to deflect with
one thing what you said you know y I
have the feeling that if Magnus would
have not won those 50 ratings from
Hikaru he would have taken from someone
else okay good point but but believe me
Magnus would have reached I don't know
his 28 79 or whatever or 80 something
was his Peak it just too much even to
remember but yeah it was not all only
Hikaru fault
right I mean a lot of a lot of
co-conspirators I love it no I totally I
totally agree but I think um there was
this time when Hikaru had a
little always found it very difficult to
face Magnus but then we saw him in
recent years being able to overcome that
and he was able to beat Magnus um I
think in the in a classical game as well
um once and that and I remember
interviewing him in jalter and he always
said that you just need that one win to
overcome somebody who you have a
difficult score against and we've seen
him do that in the Magnus Carlson
Chester at the Linder Abby and once
again a big congratulations to our first
finalist very deserving and um yes like
we're saying this is setting up this is
setting up to be a dream final and um
let's also get the final thoughts of our
audience on Twitter so let's see what
they had to say so we heard from SIU
cisu and he said GM Hikaru suffocated
dubo with boring positions but will he
survive in the final against Magnus the
World Champ seems comfortable in both
Dynamic and boring positions will he
adopt a Yan neosi cat movement uh CBC
thank you for writing in and yes Hikaru
gave us that really interesting Insight
that you know he felt that Daniel really
thrives on complex and and aggressive
and messy position so he just decided to
go Mega boring and mega solid and sort
of get Daniel out of his comfort zone
and of course uh it worked here firstly
we we have to see if Magnus makes it to
the final it looks like that's the final
that we're setting up Magnus is leading
the set by by one is leading the match
by one Set uh it's really hard to say
what's going to happen because like like
we were talking about Hikaru Nakamura
has been the only player to beat Magnus
Carlson in The Knockout uh stages of the
of the entire tour in the semi-finals
earlier in lindas it's going to be
whether it's Magnus whether it's going
to be ding it's going to be interesting
to see what works against Magnus
nobody's able to figure it out yet cisu
let's move on to the next
one and we had Raina writing in Magnus
even takes over ding screen and he sends
us a screenshot of after how he won he
is on both screens yes he did take over
that match as well uh Raina as we saw he
in fact he's been dominating this entire
tour uh thank you for sending us that
screenshot uh whatever else did we hear
on Twitter Luke writing in with great
what about bringing a tournament with
all commentators playing against each
other Yan Peter Leo Peter swiler Peter
Leo t g firstly I am uh I am just
honored to be in that company and it's
just a a big yes to whatever it is I
mean it would be a dream come true to
get a chance to play against these guys
players like Naka and maxus can do the
commentary that's not going to be a
commentary that's going to be a troll
Fest so I'm not sure how I feel yes how
do you feel about Magnus and Naka
commentating on I I I think that's a
brilliant suggestion I love it love it
love it I don't think that Magnus and
Hikaru could do the same type of justice
that you have
[Music]
done you're too you're too kind and um
yes I I actually agree with you that you
know what these guys might be really
great chess players but they got nothing
on the commentary that chess 24 has put
together together for this bingo bingo
perfect and with that of course another
another a big thank you to all our
audience to be a part of our of the tour
of engaging with us and interacting with
us and making this special because
everything that we do and everything
that we're putting together is for you
and chess 24 has has done this amazing
response in a very difficult time by
putting this Magnus Carlson chest store
together and if you would like like to
support all that's been done and to see
more of this in the coming months
because we are at the very end of this
fantastic tour that we've had if you
want to see more of that support
consider supporting chess 24 consider
supporting uh the community and right
now is there's no better time than now
to do that because not only are you
going to be supporting chess but you
will also help very talented and very
deserving businesses and small
Enterprises and entrepreneurs who have
been who have been really affected and
impacted by the by the pandemic because
50% of all premium sales are going to go
is going to go to kaas cause of helping
these businesses survive a very
difficult time and uh uh you can do that
by buying a premium membership for
yourself or gifting premium uh to to
your friends to your students we've had
several top players do that and a big
thank you and a big shout out to all of
you who have contributed to chess to the
growth of Chess By by by gifting these
premium memberships but also contributed
uh by making a difference in the world
and helping through chess helping
communities through chess uh and of
course more the good news and the action
and everything just doesn't stop because
if you haven't had enough of Chess
already for the day highly recommend
that you go check out Magnus Carlson's
free lesson on end games I mean we've
seen um we've seen this uh this guy just
just play amazingly I mean I think
throughout the tour whenever he's had
any whenever he's had any end games
we've seen the kind of plans that he
puts together the strategies how he
plays it just feels like another class
like another League completely so if you
want to get a peak into his mind John
Bartholomew and Magnus Carlson sit down
and analyze one of the games from the
world championship match and I know that
there are also exercises for you to
solve great explanations about the
different strategies on how to play the
end game and and like he was telling yes
he himself learned a lot uh during uh uh
during this course and uh through his
experience in how he's become such a
monster when it comes to endgame plays
this is just of course a a teaser to
what's to come because the Magnus touch
the end game is going to be an entire
course and I think um that's something
that all of us are looking forward to
but this one is a free lesson right now
you don't want to miss out on it so
check it out on chessel and with that
I am going to call it a night H it's uh
it's late here I'm looking forward to
tomorrow D has to win tomorrow otherwise
it's the end of the road and we will
have our second finalist big day coming
up for dingin as he's up against Magnus
Carlson playing catchup in their
semi-final bracket the score is 2-1
Magnus Carlson needs one win to advance
to the finals uh can't wait to see you
all tomorrow good night for me thank you
Tanya thank you Peter and good good
night to everyone from Happy
Holland yeah thank you everyone yes
byebye
[Music]